there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey ladies and gentlemen here we are
it's saturday once again
we've got our drinks going holy crap oh
i thought you had drank like more than
that like you were drinking and i was
like my god is it half gone already
i didn't have i didn't have it all that
full anyway oh okay so you scared me
there for a second
i thought you took like a big huge slug
of it no it's pretty strong but it's uh
you know
it's more concentrated more concentrated
oracle's waving at us hi hi everybody
thank you for dropping
by on this saturday we're doing like a
nice
fun creepy topic i mean the last last
show was fun too but it was about murder
so it's not
it's not quite as fun i kind of like the
paranormal ones better
i i know you do but it's just that we
have more fun with them
well like i said i mean i kind of i
don't know i'm kind of of two minds
about it because
the paranormal ones for me they're kind
of like a bigger pain in the ass to do
because the
you know taking notes and the stories by
them are so like nebulous
um you know true crime is much more a
matter of fact which is easier for a lot
more evidence
but um the paranormal ones i don't feel
as bad
you know like having a good time on the
show like getting all [ __ ] crazy
as what i'm talking about like the
murders of actual people which kind of
which i feel kind of bad like getting
entertainment one of the one of the few
true crime ones that i had a [ __ ]
blast with was panzram
yeah [ __ ] pants around just because
he was just such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
i mean
that dude is a [ __ ] butt pirate
running around raping men and [ __ ]
that's
at gunpoint raping bums on the train at
gunpoint
i mean that's damn right damn
like it's not and he let the women go he
had no interest in the women just the
men
it's just that's craziness that dude was
just like kind of reminds me of that it
kind of reminds me of that famous
convict from england uh bronson
yeah yeah bronson wasn't charles
broadside not that charles bronson
called himself bronson
yeah that wasn't his real name sofa sent
me the movie bronson it was good
it was i like kind of like clockwork tom
hardy was in it yeah he did a good job
he did actually that was a crazy ass
movie that's kind of how our
how i imagine panzram there's a guy like
that
yeah probably he's just somebody that
just [ __ ]
he's just like a [ __ ] psycho and he
just hated everybody yeah
yeah he's just like yeah and love to get
in trouble and love to just rape and
thank you thank you debra
thank you very much look at the little
hug look at the little butt wiggling
that's what
that's what pookie's butt does yeah
you see the wiggling butt i see it i
call her wiggle butt sometimes sophie
said that the hands around the show blew
my mind too what a psycho that's why i
sent you the bronze movie
oh okay so that makes sense it makes a
lot of sense yeah i got that same vibe
watching bronson i was like i bet your
pants around was like that
that's probably exactly right yeah oh my
god
although i gotta say bronson was kind of
lovable
yeah i mean he was kind of a piece of
[ __ ] too but not
not in the same way i know i can't
remember i don't think he killed anybody
not in the same way i mean panzram was
just like he would just
you it was like a little boy like
walking down the road he's like hey i'm
gonna rape and kill that kid yeah just
cause
yeah and he didn't have any standards
too like old dirty old [ __ ] bums and
[ __ ] he just
if it was a man he'd [ __ ] rape and
kill it or rape it
but he didn't kill them he didn't really
kill the men did he
just the boys i think he left now i
can't remember
i think he let a lot of the men go yeah
maybe but um
yeah i don't think i don't remember i
don't think panzer never killed anybody
he just when he
he would get in more trouble in prison
and just bronson didn't get bronson
yeah many people
just got sent to prison for little [ __ ]
robberies and stuff and then when he got
into prison he got into more and more
and more trouble
taking people hostage and fighting the
cops
running around well he'd take off all
his clothes and white and rub himself
down with [ __ ] vaseline to make
himself
slippery and then go and attack the
[ __ ] guards he'd be fighting 910
guards
yeah he's [ __ ] nuts getting more and
more time and more and more time the
longer he was in prison the more time he
got
they'd put him in a little cage that he
could only stand up and he'd figure out
how to work out in there he wrote a book
on how to work out in prison how to get
big in prison yeah you need a little
cage like in little babies yeah
situations that's a guy life hands him
lemons
[Laughter]
if you haven't seen the movie bronson
i really recommend it with tom hardy
he's not a real dude and that dude is
like still
he's still alive yeah yeah i think he is
yeah he's still in prison i think we
talked about him
and if you it's if you like
if you like clockwork orange it's in
that same motif i think
it kind of felt a lot like because it
had like some weird kind of like
surrealistic
elements it's a real life story about a
real
character and he's evidently england's
most famous prisoner
and they had some big prison riot and
bronson was
famous because they got some helicopter
footage of him he's standing on top of
the damn prison
on top of the prison he escaped during
the riot and he's on top of the prison
[ __ ]
acting like he's a badass with the
helicopters looking at him he's waving
and [ __ ] and that's
and he became he's a star and his fame
yeah he became more of a star in
england for like who's that [ __ ]
that's bronson
well the thing about and i'm not sure if
it's still true nowadays but something
that i
um and i might have mentioned this
before but something that um
i noticed about the culture of the uk is
they very much love
they don't love serial killers but they
very much love
convicts convicts were like gangsters
that didn't like
i mean they maybe killed people but they
only killed like other gangsters
yeah like but they like kind of lovable
criminals
well the united states was kind of like
that too especially yeah i guess so
you know during kind of prohibition era
gangsters and stuff you know what i mean
they were
because they were they were a different
kind of they were a different cut of
people back in those days
when you think about it the 20s
prohibition
era gangsters the depression was going
on
yeah if very little opportunity in the
united
states and um
if there wasn't if they had a thriving
economy those dudes wouldn't have been
criminals
you know what i mean they were they were
intelligent they didn't really want to
be criminals they just had to be well
and they were taking advantage of
prohibition yeah to like make them
try to make a buck yeah and um
so eventually what happened to a lot of
those guys if they didn't get killed if
they if they
if they lasted long enough they kind of
went straight eventually
a lot of them as individuals just
because the the situation got better
but you know some of them were veterans
they had higher iqs they had skills
they had good taste in things they were
kind of people
people didn't mind having them around
they weren't savages right
you know what i mean some of them had
were friends with the police
you know because to be a successful 20s
gangster
you had to be the kind of you had to be
a very honest criminal
you had to be somebody that a politician
or a cop would have you over to their
house and could trust you around their
families
yeah because they did go to over there
to eat and cut deals and stuff
they weren't the kind of person to they
had rules well they weren't like carl
pads around no they weren't like
[Laughter]
and they weren't even you would just
come to your house rape your sons and
[ __ ] on your walls
yeah and they weren't even like your
house they weren't even like the mexican
mob or
or some of the mexican cartels you know
i mean like i don't think you could
trust them guys i mean maybe i
might be wrong there might be some of
them they're trustworthy but just from
what i'm picking up i don't think i
trust them guys
um the old the old italian and irish 20s
gangsters united states were trustworthy
which that that kind of sounds like an
oxymoron but no like i said they have a
coat of vodka yeah
you know what i mean some some criminals
doing something right
look we're having a paranormal show
we're talking about true crime i know
ain't that something we're gonna [ __ ]
we always [ __ ] do that we gotta i
don't
know
we got some shout outs we've got some
gifts before we start the show we do
yeah did i is that camera still on uh
yeah i don't know why that's i don't
know why it won't go
it's plugged in though in it yeah so it
won't it won't hurt it no
it'll be all right yeah my boy louie
sent me a movie
that's right mr hunter he sends us so
many movies
i'm very excited about this one too yeah
check it out you guys
apocalypse apocalypse now i'm not if i'm
not mistaken mistaken
that's a steel book yes it is blu-ray
fantastic
i haven't seen this movie in like
forever so i'm like super stoked
when i was [ __ ] in the army a lot of
dudes said that i
my old army self you know i mean just my
build and the way i carried myself you
know i was actually a little classier
back then for some strange reason
but uh a lot of a lot of people that
knew me said that i reminded them of of
willard
from that movie from that movie yeah was
it captain willard
who played him in that movie what's that
charlie chane at the charlotte
charlie sheen or martin martin martin
sheen yeah yeah charlie sheena
a little people said that a lot of
people that watched that movie said ross
man it reminds me of you man if a man
you could play that role
you know and i was like yeah maybe i
could see you looking like martin sheen
when he was
when i was much younger yeah when you
know and when martin shane was much
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what i mean
but that's kind of how i carried myself
yeah you know my military bearing was a
lot like that
well when i wasn't [ __ ] up because
well that was part of the culture that's
what humans do yeah it was part of the
culture
rebecca says did you guys get disney
plus yet to view the mandalorian season
two
episode one you have to no i'm gonna get
somebody send me the blu-ray
i got it i thought about it i thought
about it i got a blue red i got a
a a uh season one i've got on a
um a [ __ ] what do you call it bojack
[ __ ] blu-ray yeah what do you call
them
not like bojack horseman
yeah bojack is just uh you know it's not
it's not
it's not the real thing what do you call
that what's what's what's the word
normal people use for that
i i don't have any idea cheap jack or
set
bow jack it's like an underground
version of it
bootleg bootleg that's it's a map yeah
bojack is boom what
army people use means the same thing tom
does it know what words but yeah
no no that was a term that we use
bojack bootleg
yeah no i'm just saying there's a
there's a cartoon show called
yeah called maniac knew exactly i was
talking about he said right there
bootleg yeah that's right
well i said bootleg
yeah well it's funny because i had
actually thought because i was watching
something on hulu and then
i was thinking about getting the hbo
add-on for this very few you guys are
gonna laugh this is the reason that i
thought about it
because for some reason the other night
oh i know what reason it was because we
were watching one of dan bell's videos
and in the background of the video
because he always puts like kind of old
music like that sounds like it's like
coming through the
you know the the sound system the mall
like it sounds all creepy and distant
everything
and the song that was playing was uh
magic
by olivia newton-john which actually i
kind of like that song
yeah yeah we got to talk about i always
liked that song so for some reason i was
like what i was like this song was
insanity right
and i go yeah man i forget and i was
like we should watch santa too
[Laughter]
for you 13 o'clock fans my first [ __ ]
encounter with [ __ ] xanadu was when
i was at my aunt lois's house and read
michael red who was in the book now
mountain poultry guys
showed me because oh man this is a new
movie you know olivia newton john you
know thinking he's playing it and it's
called xanadu and i'm watching it
and i was i was kind of getting into it
first 20 minutes and he goes
it's not that good though
[Laughter]
and that was that was that was that was
all i remembered about him
and going yeah
yeah like so for some reason like the
other night because we had watched that
dan bell video so many times it had that
song in it i was like we should totally
watch this yes we ran it we ran insanity
and so
somebody requested that we actually
review santa do
you we probably will wonder because i'll
put it in there because of the
the greco-roman [ __ ] mythology the
greco
i saw it when i was a kid but dialysis i
remembered
very little about it he wanted to know
my analysis from a [ __ ] a
mythological
[ __ ] standpoint i thought it was good
i totally forgot gene kelly was in that
jane kelly was in it
it's just a corny musical it was very
very very california i was in cut
growing up in california at the time
that they filmed this movie it did have
a very authentic
california 1980 feel that's the way
california seemed to be it was it was a
good place
but you know florida feels like that now
california isn't like that anymore
except you don't see people in like
little bitty [ __ ] velour shores
roller skating down boardwalks or
anything nothing i know of i haven't
seen that for many years
but uh olivia was looking fantastic in
it
uh just a [ __ ] perfect late 70s early
80s [ __ ] chick
you know that they had back then [ __ ]
it was it's kind of like along the lines
of greece
it was a musical like that well there
wasn't as much of a story
let me know i feel like it was just like
a series of
music videos with kind of like a little
bit of a story like sandwiched in
between
very much a feel-good type movie
it was kind of like a gender swap
version
oh [ __ ] superman instead of a greek
god coming down and meeting a woman lois
lane
this is a greek goddess coming down and
meeting a man
coming out of the mural she came out of
a mural a mural of the [ __ ]
of the mall food court what it looked
like which
i was like man that looks like a food
court it did look like the food court
it's like yeah we put the we put the
nine muses on there yeah nine muses
and i liked it though because they it
made a lot of sense because they
jumped out and her and her not her and
her eight other sisters
they were all different races and ethnic
groups they were like
must be physical perfection in terms of
beauty and everything
for all for a global kind of
market you know what i mean they had
they had like asian ones and indian ones
and black ones and white ones of
different kinds and [ __ ] different
ethnic groups
and they all come out and they go off in
different directions
of the earth so they can all blend in
wherever they go
and the whole thing is is that they're
supposed to enhance a man's artistic
ability
and to bring him and to develop his
personality i guess this would be a good
way to
uh to describe it and one of them ends
up in california right there near the
food court
that one had to be doesn't happen to be
olivia
with the with the roller skates that and
there's rollers they were like knee-high
like leg warmers
shoulder [ __ ] dresses like [ __ ]
the
fleetwood like [ __ ] what's in the
girl from fleetwood mac what's her name
stevie nice stevie nicks dresses and
[ __ ]
you can't get any more 1980 than that
you really can
i mean it was it was so 1980 that i was
just
good singing good acting everything
totally normal there's no
abnormality in the damn movie it all
kind of although i told him i said we
we're watching this now i said the song
xanadu is going to be stuck in my head
[Music]
asks uh did you ever see the movie
sergeant pepper's lonely hearts club
yeah i liked it i did
love it and this that movie is like a
guilty pleasure of mine yeah
dumb as [ __ ] i really like a bunch of
times when i was a kid
yeah and i [ __ ] loved that was my
first
introduction to the bdsm scene with mr
mustard and them damn two [ __ ]
vinyl robot chicks man sexy as hell i
was like yeah that was a weird movie
yeah i was i was like
alice was in it and aerosmith was in
there i was probably like
12 and i'm going yeah the pgs i need a
girlfriend dresses just like that
and it happened it happened it happened
many times
jenny was one of them just just like
that
they're fetish outfits it's a good movie
man i like sergeant pepper
if you tila if you like sgt peppers you
got to see
phantom of the paradise which is a it's
a musical yeah we reviewed that one
it's a rock musical anyway it's like a
it's like a yeah it's a rock 70s rock
musical that has
every version of 70s music in it
ranging from metal to disco to early new
wave
it's it's just a good story and it's
[ __ ] off the wall real well made
um what was funny about xanadu is that i
remembered it being a disco movie
but it's not disco it's prog rock it's
prog rock yeah it was elo yeah
i remembered it being a disco movie too
maybe i was thinking of something i
guess because the roller skates
the roller skates i guess it was yeah um
yeah and the sgt peppers movie
um somebody met like oracle mentioned
yeah steve martin was in that
he was uh you know maxwell yeah maxwell
silverhammer yeah
and uh george burns was in it he was mr
kite um
there was all it was it was all-star
cast
dj maniac says i'm over here acting like
i don't remember the leather man from
the [ __ ]
from the village people of course i
remember the leather man from and the
indian
and the sailor [ __ ] you know what i
mean
construction the construction worker the
lineman
you see when you're a kid you don't
really understand what it is you're
seeing you know what i'm talking about
you don't really
you don't really know you can't make
that leap it's just dudes
it wasn't sexualized or anything but
[ __ ]
yeah and it's in its time
actually no i'm gonna say i'm gonna say
the village people music it
is a work of pop music genius actually
i think they're well people are still
talking about their houses nowadays yeah
very
very much they knew exactly what they
were doing although i don't think it
tops bgs
bg's [ __ ] i kind of have a software
from bg's actually yeah
well i mean all of that kind of music
that came out because like i said
during that time period it's like as
much as i didn't like
i don't know if i'm gonna say i didn't
like it at the time because i think i
did
but it's like now even as much as i like
you know my
my regular [ __ ] my punk my goth my all
that kind of stuff but it's like
if [ __ ] barry manilow comes on i'm
not gonna turn that [ __ ] off i'm gonna
tell you right now
or tom jones or anything like that i'll
be like all right
let's see where we're going with this
but it's funny because after we finished
watching xanadu
i was actually gonna say now i kind of
feel like watching sergeant pepper's on
the arts club band
and then we can watch the pirate movie
with christy mcnichol
which is another one that i watched like
a million times growing up which is
probably
terrible i saw that before i saw
the pirates of penzance um the movie
version
with uh [ __ ] uh [ __ ] what's his name
kevin
did the guy that fish called wanda um
but yeah so
uh anyway yeah is asking about what was
phantom of the of the paradise was it
like phantom of the opera
yeah it was sort of kind of like the
rocky horror picture show as well yeah
that's what sophie said
kind of like the rocky horror picture so
it's about a guy who
is trying to get a record contract
through a through a
bad real evil kind of record company
i don't remember all of it he signs his
soul over to some kind of the doesn't he
sign his soul well paul williams was
the death of the devil essentially yeah
and something bad happens to him and he
comes back as the [ __ ]
phantom of the parents paradise and he's
all [ __ ] up yeah
and if it's got like all the great rock
music of the 70s
is kind of there's no famous artist
doing the music but it's sure kind of
everything kind of sounds like it was
made by bowie or aerosmith or yeah so
when that's
just priest velvet gold mine it's like
the velvet gold mine
which came a long life you ever seen
that movie it's like a parallel
universe version of all that stuff
because
you just got to see it just also jessica
harper who was in yeah the original
suspicion
yeah she is also in this movie and she's
young and lovely but uh i'm not sure if
that's really her singing
i think it is well the thing that stood
out to me in it is that [ __ ] it was
uh
um the phantom of the paradise he's
gonna commit some kind of a damn
assassination and the [ __ ]
the carbine that he uses was the same
[ __ ] weapon that [ __ ]
um um oh [ __ ]
oh what's his name used i'll remember it
later i'll remember it later
he always try to remember what's his
name like yeah yeah those like jenny
knows who i'm [ __ ] talking about
you know the guy with the head with a
hard hat in your arm
you know what i mean i don't know um
eddie murphy did a movie about him
we just saw it the great one dolomite
dome rudy ray moore
rudy ray moore and the dolomite movie
pulled out of them
i think it's called an h r carbine
it's just a [ __ ] california's take on
an uzi they didn't make very many of
them they still make them though
it's kind of just a weird ass [ __ ]
gun but it was just kind of strange that
i saw that in phantom of the paradise
and then i saw it in that rudyard more
flick i was like oh man that's that same
gun
you know and if you're into guns and
[ __ ] you you know
i didn't know what it was but that was
like a very [ __ ] obscure
cool gun like something that james bond
would have
you know what i mean in both of those
movies but it's like
kind of forgotten now if you have one
it's like a classic
it's like a cult classic but you know
gun dudes you know they're like or
oracle said i think it was her singing
didn't she sing for shock treatment as
well yeah i think you're actually right
about that
i haven't seen shock treatment for a
while that's the sequel to rocky horror
picture show in case you guys did not
know
not as good but it was still pretty fun
michael says was i the only one that was
dumb when i was a little kid and thought
the actors on the shows
sang the theme songs i think i thought
that too
about a couple of shows so you probably
aren't the only one
[Laughter]
all right so we actually had another i
said thank you to louis for sending us
apocalypse now
i also had a couple of other shout outs
um
to get back here where i have a little
bit more room yeah go back there with
like baby yoda
yeah i'll come back baby baby we have to
[ __ ] have like a commanding view of
everything and like
access to this drink well yeah you need
like all the
he needs to sit back there and kind of
like survey i feel small as [ __ ] right
now
my hormones are coming back into balance
now i feel small
now i feel [ __ ] small because he's
always complaining about i swear to god
you guys it's like
i'm either big or small i'm either
bloated and pregnant with all the
[ __ ] small
like welcome to mel welcome to my world
this is like what
this is what women have been going
through since like they first go through
puberty when they're like
10 or 11 years old i feel like i got
[Laughter]
yeah there's no difference it's it well
there is
i'm just like i don't know if you look
can see it's just you know you feel it
and then your mind takes over you know
what i mean i told you
it's just like it's just like if you're
a girl you're pregnant did you get me
pregnant
yeah sorry about that just like in
species like was that these was it
species
wasn't there a movie where there was a
female alien that was trying to
impregnate male aliens i mean other than
alien i don't know which that alien was
just like i don't care if you're a man
or woman i'm gonna impregnate you
alien well yeah that's what i just said
um also oh the other shout outs i wanted
to thank
melanie for her paypal donation she
gives us one
uh quite often so thank you very much
for that also want to thank michael for
his
uh patreon increase he was a patron
before and then he just like
upped his support this week so thank you
very very much for that
you guys are awesome tammy says lol tom
pregnant yeah it is very funny to think
about
you're saying i need to access my flakka
is tom gonna have an anal baby
[Laughter]
oh no they also said um
under the skin yeah but maybe that's
what i was thinking of yeah that was a
weird ass movie
i don't think you saw that somebody said
that i was i was even dumber when i was
a kid
because i thought all the people on tv
knew each other and they all lived
together
i did i remember that yeah i kind of
feel like thinking that like when i was
real little
i thought rodney allen rippy knew knew
michael jackson when they were kids back
in the 70s i was about five because they
kind of looked alike
yeah i thought i thought rodney allen
ripped was part of the jackson fives
oh okay yeah cause i i saw a little
michael jackson singing
right and then i see [ __ ] little
rodney already talking about the whopper
you guys don't know and i said oh yeah
they know each other
and then yeah i was in all the tv people
though yeah
it could they're living they're living
there they're all in the jackson 5.
and then it was funny because my mom
take me to the pike when i was a little
kid and just out in los angeles
out of l.a and and i see rodney allen
rip your mom
he's with his mom i was like six six and
he was like six
and my mom and his mom were talking and
i see rodney right he's up in the
[ __ ] ferris wheel you know with his
mom and [ __ ] and it's just you know it's
funny
i was going like where's michael don't
you guys
yeah we're michael jackson yeah because
they were all little kids you know
oh yeah they're all on tv they were all
on tv together they were all black so
they all know each other
of course all the white people knew each
other too
you know i just thought i actually i
thought i just thought he was in the
jackson 5.
that's just kind of like wherever you're
from in the world if you ever go to
another country
and then like people ask you hey where
are you from and you're and i'm like
like for example like when i was in the
uk and they'd be like hey where are you
from let's say i'm from florida i'm from
uh originally i'm from daytona beach and
they'd be like oh i know this person in
miami and blah blah i'm like do you
do you know that miami is five hours
away from daytona beach right
at the point that i went to the uk i'd
never even been to miami because it was
like so
far um i've been there since but
i i just thought it was funny that
people thought everybody in like america
like knew each other even though i was
like dude i've never
been to miami and i've lived in florida
my whole life i'm like that's like a
five hour drive hardly anybody does that
but yeah so are we ready to start
talking about goals go ahead and talk
about it
they all had aphros yeah i like the afro
though man
they're trying to bring that back i'm
down i saw
i saw i saw a chick in a porn scene man
she was [ __ ] looking really good
[ __ ] and she had a huge [ __ ] afro
that thing was like about three foot
across yeah yeah like three foot across
just booty and big old [ __ ] implants
and [ __ ] but
it looked good it looked really good to
bring that back that was like the
chicken
from the painting over hallorann's bed
in yeah
like the chick from how over halloween's
been
just like that i could even give it oh
you can i can even dig up her name
but uh i saw that thing and i was like
oh man it looks cool
that's a hairstyle that should come back
it's time for that comeback i mean it
depends on the it's just like any other
hairstyle
it looks good it looks well it looks
everything looks good
yeah it looks good but um you know what
i mean
so i mean it's just like any you have to
have like the right shaped head
it's just kind of like how some chicks
can be can have like a shaved head and
it looks really good
and then some people like me have a
shaved head and it looks
horrifying my head just looks like a
giant white marble yeah so you know what
i mean it doesn't look that bad
when it was partially shaved it well
partially shaved is fine yeah but
um i i just fear that totally shaved it
would look like really really bad
and i'm like too scared to try it even
though i'm sick of my [ __ ] hair and
sometimes i wish i could shave it all
off yeah i guess i could
shave it all off and just get away it
wouldn't be any good i don't think you
don't need a wig you don't need it you
don't need a hair system
a hair system if y'all don't know i cut
hair i cut her hair all the time
i used to [ __ ] i used to [ __ ]
shave her [ __ ] side walls and give
her the [ __ ] sideburns so
the goth haircut where it was just
sideburns
and then skin and she just had a top and
then [ __ ]
and bangs i might do that again
when warm weather comes again because
it's like i just it took me like two
years
to grow it all back now hair is long
enough to do that and my hair is very
very long it's like i always have it
tied up because it's a pain in the ass
but um
yeah my hair is like both halfway down
my back yeah and
when it's summertime here my hair is
like really really thick so it's always
kind of like for a long
time i would just keep all the underside
shaved because it was so much cooler
yeah and you know plus when i washed it
it was like you know it takes forever
to dry i can do that to you again yeah
probably
i should probably get rid of because
it's so heavy and it's just like
if you want me to do it i can do it i
mean it takes 20
15 minutes i'm yeah i'm thinking about
it and just leave just the sideburns
like i did last time
mark says i should do dreadlocks i have
so i have considered that
dreadlocks are [ __ ] problematic man
they [ __ ] stink and they're [ __ ]
you can't get them wet
yeah you can't get them wet they'll go
sour on you
yeah if you're gonna get dreadlocks just
[ __ ] get a system get a hair
assistant
i was just thinking of size pearling in
this hair club for men
and also those like late night
infomercials that were essentially just
black spray paint that you like sprayed
on the top of your head those were
[ __ ] hilarious
tina says she's related to diana ross
beyonce
condoleezza rice and cleopatra ain't
that some [ __ ]
that's funny well you gonna [ __ ] lay
it out there like that tina you got to
prove it we need to see some pictures to
prove it
whenever when whenever me and jenny talk
[ __ ] we got pictures to prove this [ __ ]
i'm waiting for one of y'all to call me
out on some of these wild tales this is
i got pictures i got a picture
i i haven't seen i've been involved with
some crazy [ __ ] jenny can [ __ ] bag me
i have a picture of you eating
pizza rolls out of it out of a litter
box yeah yeah eating it's really
actually on a stage in front of [ __ ]
hundreds of people
doing this and i have a picture of me on
a stage
um with a dildo rubbing up
like somebody like this girl that's like
in this leather outfit and she was all
covered with whipped cream that's right
at the fetch club whipped cream or
shaving cream or something i can't
remember all kind of sex [ __ ] it was a
long time ago
we we didn't we weren't nude though no
no
it was it was all part of the contest
everyone had clothes it was part of
these contests that we were at we we did
some finished classes i think it was a
tr it was a [ __ ] club really that
where a
fetish [ __ ] was happening well it was a
it's a gay bar but they had like fetish
nights
yeah it had a real good theater and my
friend was running
what happened to that place a friend of
mine was running a really cool event
there where they'd have [ __ ] contests
and [ __ ] just funny competitions and
dance night and everything it was good
what was the name of that place
escape escape well this club was called
southern knights yeah southern knights
some of the the night was called escape
yeah um yeah it was kind of a goth
industrial fetish [ __ ] night
yeah and like i said they had a really
nice theater in there and they would
just do these ridiculous some of them
were like disgusting
but um like the games and stuff yeah um
and you know but you could win [ __ ] you
could win like a hundred dollar bar to
add you can win like
this kind of [ __ ] but you had to do like
really really good [ __ ] like this
zach would have loved that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] pansexual
it was like a smorgasbord all kinds of
tops and power bottoms and [ __ ]
zach would have been [ __ ] just thrown
himself into a sea of gays
peter loved that [ __ ] he's been riding
the wave like a tsunami of
ass
what's wrong with he laughing at i was
gonna say that's the next chuck tingle
book the tsunami of ass
this tsunami of ass and the sea of gays
yeah well it was like a crowd you know
[ __ ] right man
zach knows what i'm talking about we've
been going on for like 43 [ __ ]
minutes
i'm getting drunk how many like how many
comments am i gonna get on this channel
are you guys gonna talk about the ghost
or what
no no we're just warming up there's a
free show
there's always a free show we don't
really get that many comments about it i
guess because
like people that are like cranky about
that kind of [ __ ] like don't watch live
streams you just go yeah
and um you know wouldn't watch because i
always like you know mark it's gonna be
like it's gonna be a couple hours this
show probably it probably will
you know found it pounded in the butt by
a sea of gays
exactly exactly you see he got a picture
we got a classy [ __ ] crowd out there
that [ __ ] gives me good quality
comments they've been
keeping up with things and remembering
things they know the culture of the show
we have a whole culture the whole
culture behind this show
sorry i just got distracted by the on
air sign i put it on a different
setting today so it's kind of like going
away like quicker than usual
yeah so it's like doing a weird [ __ ]
behind my head like because i have like
i have like the program that goes with
it and there's all these like different
settings
most of them don't even i mean most of
them like look pretty similar
but there's a couple that are good but
i've never used this one before this is
the
gayest thing i've ever said but can we
appreciate how beautiful the interior of
the queen mary is
it is beautiful it's all like art deco
and stuff
now before we start this show i want to
tell you guys you know
growing up in california for like my
first 13 years
i used to pass the queen mary and the
spruce goose all the time
yeah i was from carson i was from carson
california and moved to long beach
but was around in long beach in signal
hill i went to military school there and
everything
but i went to the same school [ __ ]
quentin tarantino in [ __ ] middle
in elementary school which is dominguez
elementary
um although he was a couple years older
than me i remember him
i thought i had a class picture with him
but then i did the res you did the
research and he was a couple years older
than me so we weren't in the same class
yeah but you saw him around saw him out
in the field all the time that little
[ __ ]
that little [ __ ] little [ __ ] yeah
he was weird even back then he was just
like he was even worse
how do you see him now he was worse when
he was a kid well just goes to show
that like sometimes if you're weird in a
particular way you can become a [ __ ]
yeah well he watched it he worked at the
video rental store up there
yeah just up the street and [ __ ] i
know what he's talking about that was a
few blocks from where i was [ __ ]
born you know and um yeah
also behind the school there that's
where jesse james motorcycle
shop ended up being later on oh that's
right i forgot all about it
that's where the railroad tracks behind
the school and behind that was where
jesse james placed that
when i was a little kid we used to walk
up and down those railroad tracks
looking for dead dogs
because that's what you do when you're a
little boy let's go find some dead stuff
well yeah that's that's the whole
premise yeah you got the body that's
stephen king
novella that they yeah
and then we walk down into the wildlife
preserve and [ __ ] jump in the water
and try to catch frogs and [ __ ]
we were catching [ __ ] in california
there's some crazy [ __ ] and
like we're [ __ ] trying to catch frogs
and then [ __ ] we were catching
crawfish and trying to cook them without
any seasoning or anything
trying to eat them like we were like we
were [ __ ] wild man we're like seven
or eight you know
trying to cook the [ __ ] cooking they
were like two inches long
they tasted terrible well yeah i bet
shit's not ripe yet yeah and that was
where that was where
um right what i'm talking about is where
in greece they filmed the [ __ ] car
chase
in the [ __ ] flood control system okay
yeah the drag race we used to go
in that flood control system all the
time that's where the giant ants from
the movie them were
used to go in there and look for those
[ __ ] ants because you gotta like keep
that like
gotta be vigilant we've been walking
about the [ __ ] giant ants and we went
down in there with [ __ ] homemade
torches i've talked told the story
already
and it's also around the place where
where [ __ ] arnold schwarzenegger
jumped the fat boy off and [ __ ]
landed in there during terminators
yeah yeah that was the area where that's
a very famous area
yeah it's yeah i was gonna say i never
caught any crawfish but
for a time when i was younger we lived
in a house that had like this little
strip of land that had like a little
swamp area in it yeah
we had some bobcats and [ __ ] in the
backyard but me and my brother's
favorite thing to do was catch big old
buckets of tadpoles
catch big old buckets and then we'd
raise them until they turned into frogs
and be like be free little frogs we
didn't eat them we used to catch
tadpoles down there too
[Laughter]
and then every summer i'd go to my
because my parents were divorced every
summer would [ __ ] go down mississippi
so
half my life and all the summers i spent
in mississippi and then
then and then [ __ ] i was in detroit
then i went to mississippi and i lived
in mississippi and
mississippi with some [ __ ] wild [ __ ]
man i went back there and i was just
like oh yeah
that's why i left i forgot but um yeah
you do forget and then you go back but
i'll tell you what oh yeah
uh biloxi in the gulf coast area is
[ __ ] evidently [ __ ] off a chain
now
our friend gia moved there she loves it
oh she moved to
she oh she went to uh because she went
to new orleans right and then and then
she went to biloxi
biloxi is actually kind of better than
new orleans right now the casino scene
and everything and
just built up that mississippi gulf
coast is not what it used to be a lot
like florida
yeah interesting the south is not the
same the south rose again
we got [ __ ] four space programs
we got all the car factories now all the
people are moving here
yeah so if you said we kept the cool
animals we found not killing them
yeah we had um also we had hermit crabs
we had a whole big bucket of those
my brother caught a pygmy rattlesnake in
our backyard he tried to keep that for a
pet but my mom was like yeah no
might want to let that go in the woods
because you know they're kind of
poisonous
so you uh want to talk about the queen
mary yeah let's talk about three and
there that's good
man i got like half a drink left we're
gonna be so [ __ ] happy yeah
i'm just trying to catch up with the
comments i would
yeah i was actually out walking the
other day like on the
on the seminole craft trail and there
had been a really big rainstorm like the
night before and like [ __ ] had flooded
there's this one
house these poor people that live in
this house i don't know
like why they don't move or whatever
hold on one second but dj maniac you got
[ __ ] dreadlocks
talking about how beautiful here i
thought this is i thought dj maniac was
a guy
[Laughter]
and i'm looking at the foot i'm looking
at this well that's i'm looking at the
icon it's actually a girl i think we'll
see there you go i didn't know
can't assume you make an ass out of you
and yes right
that's what they say nancy let's talk
about their hair they're all talking
about hair and [ __ ]
hair yeah um yeah so
i was out for a walk the other day and
like this [ __ ] this house
their backyard every time it rains hard
it just floods and there's like this big
huge lake in their [ __ ] backyard
and they have to pump it out every time
so it's like and it really really smells
and like so i was going for a walk and
it was like just this big lake in their
backyard and like there was [ __ ]
sandhill cranes it was cattle egrets it
was if they're like whoo new lake
and all across the path were thousands
of teeny tiny little
baby frogs like trying to get to the
other side like i guess because there
was another swamp over there and they
were all jumping so i had to like
kind of go like that like stuff maniac
is a guy
he looks like rob zombie okay i look
like rob zombie if you ordered him off
of
wish
that's [ __ ] hilarious that really
conjured a picture
[Laughter]
this wasn't what i ordered hilarious
i'm gonna give that [ __ ] star oh
my god that's like the thing
when you're the top of the list that's
the funniest thing ever i'm moving you
to the top of the list
that's like the [ __ ] i would say
oh my god i liked them i did too
every and everybody knows what you mean
if you say that i know exactly we've all
been burned by wish we
know he put the image in my head
all right so today
what army buddy of mine ordered ordered
some ballistic body armor off a wish
it had to [ __ ] it was a plate carrier
with the [ __ ] but with the [ __ ]
plate in it
and he showed it to me it was a [ __ ]
sheet of plastic
[ __ ] is like about that thick every now
and then this sheet of plastic that was
his ballistic
heaven says ballistic armor bulletproof
vestment of plastic
i every now and then i hear somebody
ordering something and it's fine
but 99 of the time every time you order
something off of wish
they just like pull pictures from google
and put it on there it doesn't have
anything to do with what you were
ordering
nothing whatsoever it's like i think
i've ordered one article of clothing off
there and it was completely different
than what i ordered so i was just but i
mean it was only like five or six bucks
or something so i was just like oh well
lesson learned and i just didn't order
anything
else off of there you know what i mean i
mean there's a reason why everything out
there is so cheap just saying
but yeah you might get lucky but i
wouldn't count on it
so uh let's talk about the queen mary
you ready yeah go ahead you sure
yeah i'm just checking out okay you sure
yeah i'm ready man
okay as soon as i start talking as soon
as no no i've hit my [ __ ] stride
i've hit my [ __ ] stride and then
i've hit my stride dj mandy i said i
ordered the nicolas cage tracksuit off
of wish only thing wrong with it was
they used the wrong face i wanted
nicholas rage
[Laughter]
you're on fire you are on fire
[Laughter]
tara says you will never get lucky do
not do it yeah i wouldn't advise it i
wouldn't advise it
i mean one time out of 100 maybe you'll
get something
approximating what you ordered but most
of the time
we're mango badger is he in here he must
not be here i saw i
i saw him earlier he isn't here that's
not earlier i haven't seen any flash
bulbs sometimes that [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is the time of the month where
[ __ ] mango badger sends me some
goddamn flash bulbs i'm looking for
money
he has no shame none whatsoever
sophie says does anyone else get bizarre
wish ads for ideas on social media like
things that look sexual but you're not
sure
i think i know what you're talking about
i think i got one today actually maybe
on facebook or instagram or something
and i'm like looking at it going what we
almost
like is that a vibrator we almost get
into the foot we
almost keep getting to the queen mary
but we keep getting sidetracked
and almost sidetracked this [ __ ]
again almost
i figured you were that's why i couldn't
get to like there's a damn bell
dead mall video where in the beginning
he's got these people talking about the
stimulator
oh yeah i know it's starting and [ __ ]
she's going the stimulation i get from
this thing i'm going what is that a
[ __ ] vibrator what is that thing a
little [ __ ] pocket rocket yeah she
said
the first time she used it yeah i was
brought to tears
yeah i'm going that must be a pocket
rocket that's what i thought i used that
[ __ ] on my first wife in a [ __ ]
pocket right she loved that [ __ ]
okay that's right and then they have
evil knievel come in
going the pocket right the stimulator is
the [ __ ] this that number what's
called a stimulator i mean
what the [ __ ] is a stimulator that's
what i said i was like what is that
it looked like a little damn d-cell
battery it looked like something you put
on some chick's [ __ ] just [ __ ]
vibrate the [ __ ] out of it right that's
what i
said yeah that's what it looks like you
thought it was right yeah we looked it
up
i looked that [ __ ] up you looked it up
and said i couldn't believe it i [ __ ]
started
listening to this [ __ ] this is hilarious
first of all that company got sued
bigger than [ __ ] the stimulator did not
stimulate any kind of muscle healing
muscle growth yeah they were making they
were trying to they were trying
to sure all it was was the ignition
module
out of a goddamn charcoal grill you know
you press the button it was click
click and it sends a voltage yeah to to
light the burners
that's all it was yeah and soon as i
realized yeah that's exactly what that
is
we've got a charcoal grill out there and
i looked underneath the bottom of it and
that's what it is
they just had put put it it just
emulated it just wasn't in the damn
charcoal grill
it had two little knobs on it where you
could hold it between your fingers and
it would shock you
so it's like that's all it was so it's
like a low-key taser it's a taser
which you could use that on your [ __ ] on
your nipples if you're into that
but it's not gonna you wouldn't get off
on that [ __ ] no
no i i don't know maybe it was paulson
but yeah that's a different thing you
couldn't pause it faster i can't believe
we're talking about this
well well that's the thing i was like
that's even lamer than what i thought it
was
yeah because you know how for a long
time you get like these old like this is
back in the [ __ ] 70s and 80s
you get these catalogs from like [ __ ]
like mail order with like finger hut and
[ __ ] like that
like young people don't know what i'm
talking about but you used to get that
and they would have sex toys there were
clearly sex toys
but you couldn't call them that because
in some states
or at least back then i don't know about
now like alabama and [ __ ] like that you
couldn't technically sell
like dildos or vibrators or something
like it through the mail
so they had to call them something else
they had home like neck massagers or
they had to call them something else but
they were obviously vibrators
so i kind of thought that that was the
situation with these
yeah even though they were small but
like you said i thought it was like a
pocket rocket yeah
those things were [ __ ] fire man yeah
well david took a lot of load off me
back in the day
i didn't have not as good as a rabbit
but rabbits are very very expensive i
had to take i had to take at least a
good one
right they took a lot of load off of me
with my first wife
[ __ ] i could sit back there and just
take a break and just [ __ ]
well yeah you just hold it there yeah
[Laughter]
anyway anyway anyway hold on mike
michael said eve evil had game and
i'm gonna we're gonna have to do a show
just about evil we should probably
i could [ __ ] go on and on about evil
knievel i i'm a bit
a big admirer of evil knievel he was
an imperfect man you know what i mean he
had issues but he was a [ __ ] man god
damn it
he was he was a [ __ ] man
that man man man they don't make men
like that anymore that [ __ ] was
willing to die
he was willing to die to entertain you
he felt like he was a gladiator in an
arena
you know i mean betting with his life
and he was he wouldn't use any safety
equipment
me just riding on my bikes i wear a full
[ __ ] body arm
spinal protection [ __ ] oh my [ __ ]
jenny's
nose i [ __ ] i'm not feeding you baby
food if you get [ __ ] paralyzed i went
down just
at 70 miles an hour on my [ __ ] bike
[ __ ] i was beat the [ __ ] up pissing
blood
oh now it's 70 miles an hour that's
about seven when he first
when it first happened several years ago
he told me he was going no faster than
40.
and then as the years have gone on the
speed has gone up and up and
well even back then i knew he was going
much faster than he told me he was going
because he didn't want
to tell me i was pissing blood and [ __ ]
too
she couldn't get me out of my clothes
nope i was just i felt i had to bring
the day that it happened
he called me at work because this was
when i used to work i was working at
that stupid
place that did like the [ __ ] like all
the uh
the printing of all this [ __ ] because i
wrecked my [ __ ] too man
yeah and he calls me at lunchtime and i
was like freaking out i was like do you
need me to come home oh my god are you
all right and stuff and he's like no no
don't come home i'm fine
and i was like are you [ __ ] serious
are you fine don't [ __ ] with me like
that and i was like flipping out
and then like i get home at like [ __ ] it
was late because that place was [ __ ]
far away
i get home at like 6 30 or 7 30. he is
laying on the bed
i ugh move man i was rock solid just
[ __ ] so sore
he told me i brought him mcdonald's i
stopped at mcdonald's on my way home
from work and like bought him
brought him a big mac he couldn't even
sit up to eat the but i had to put it
like on his chest
and like push it toward his mouth
it was like i had been tenderized like
meat tenderizer yeah
and you had armor on i was wearing armor
but you were like where
the where the armor didn't because the
armor was rubbed out wherever
it was like i'd been beaten up with a
baseball bat
and i i had [ __ ] that wasn't my only
accident you know what i mean [ __ ] i
got my military pension because of
motorcycle accidents yeah that wasn't
even your worst
that wasn't even my worst one all right
but it was pretty bad
i am evil knievel me and evil are very
similar
i would say although he's dumber than me
but braver that dude was brave i
wouldn't do that [ __ ] that he did
but he that [ __ ] was dumb and braver
two sides of the city he was making
money though he was making a lot of fun
no he knew the risks he knew the risk
yeah but let me tell you something about
the snake canyon jump
he pulled that shoot too early he had
his hand on that damn shoot release
he doesn't want to admit it but everyone
has theorized why'd that [ __ ] shoot
come out
when he did the launch he had his hand
on the [ __ ] shoot release
and the g-force [ __ ] caused him to
pull the goddamn
shoot release which caused him to foil
the snake canyon jump
in the rocket yeah well
and the guy that told made the rocket
said don't put your hand on that [ __ ]
release
and then he did they did everything
don't put your hand on that release
that's dudes man they don't listen well
i think what he thought is he thought he
was going to black out under the origin
under the g-force
which you know that's a validation he
wouldn't be awake
for to pull the [ __ ] chute but i
think he did black out under the g-force
and it caused him to pull the [ __ ]
shoe
right which he should he would have come
back alive
he would have come back awake yeah you
know what i mean
and it wasn't that much g's that many
juices it wasn't that many
too many stuff too many stuff been
drinking too much this
okay fourth drawer down said and this is
why women live longer than men
that's true and that's why if you read
all the darwin awards books it's
90 95 percent men
because women just generally they're
like no talking about it i like being
alive too much
tila tila and sophie are talking about
lip enhancers and [ __ ]
off a [ __ ] wish tila you never did
friend the show on facebook
i i said that one two or three weeks ago
i don't remember yeah i didn't get a
friend request
you probably said it when i was like lit
oh yeah
never did get a friend request thomas
super dave oh my god i remember super
dave
super dave was [ __ ] cool right there
yeah
no i'm not super dave i do he's not
still around is he no
but super dave super david really didn't
do a whole lot of [ __ ]
well his kind of whole thing was he was
it was almost kind of like i don't know
it was like a parody of evil knievel but
it kind of
wasn't it like a local parody of the
naval
yeah like that's the that's the bible i
used to watch
has not been beaten to this day yes it
hasn't
he was making huge jumps on a [ __ ]
harley sportster
which that was never designed to be in
the air
dudes that are doing dudes that are
doing these big jumps now they're on
[ __ ]
dirt bikes yeah they were meant to be in
there yeah
they're meant for that [ __ ] he was on a
harley [ __ ] sportster
which is shitty you know i mean that's a
that's a death trap
you know to be in the air it's okay on
the ground but to be in the air
you're [ __ ] crazy yeah yeah real
crazy well you'd have to be to do that
kind of [ __ ] though
jump in all those buses with something
that today would just be that would be
not that's not even close to a sport
bike not even close
and he was doing it that [ __ ]
had serious balls and he wouldn't wear
any damn armor
an engineer came up and says look man i
got all this new stuff i can
armor you to wear armors for [ __ ]
yeah that's what he said he says well
then the danger isn't there and the
suspense and no one will watch no one
will watch that's what he said he says
he's got to be
they want to see my body get broken but
he said they want no
he said they want to see me die yeah
well yeah
and and i think that's why most people
watch [ __ ] like nascar and yeah like
that too
it's like they're like well oh man no
one crashed [ __ ] that
no but they were gonna aren't they had a
dude that was hit and the dude they were
talking about was thomas he
had to he didn't develop kevlar but he
knew how to turn kevlar into armor
right and he was going to make him a
kevlar armored reinforced [ __ ]
racing suit which [ __ ] that's what i
would have wore
but you know what i mean yeah you'd
still get busted up but
chances are you'd live there are some
famous slow-motion shots a [ __ ] evil
hitting the [ __ ] ground in that
leather and all his limbs are just
crumpling up and rolling and slowing in
all directions
just about every goddamn bone broken in
his body i can't even watch that [ __ ]
it's just like oh
and then a few and then then a year
later did it again
yeah he was just [ __ ] crazy he was
crazy but i respect him i respected evil
yeah just a mean red deck somebody wrote
some bad [ __ ] about him
cheating on his wife so what does he do
beat that [ __ ] with a baseball
bat
go to prison for it
[Laughter]
evil made it clear that if you said some
[ __ ] about him he'd take a baseball bat
to you
and guess what they never wrote any [ __ ]
about him again it does work
that kind of [ __ ] does work you just
gotta be willing to go to jail
you know yeah yeah
[Laughter]
all right we are now one hour and four
minutes in it's time to do the show okay
appreciate it time to do the show you
see look
look i know other channels that'll just
let it run on the screen saver for an
hour until everybody shows up
at least we're entertaining for that
hour that's true yeah i'm talking about
dance monkeys dance that's what we're
doing yeah this is free entertainment
it is until you gave me some money and
it's not free
but even so i mean people pay for like
[ __ ] you pay for internet access you
pay for shutter you pay for netflix you
pay for all that kind of stuff
oh man yeah right yeah
don't wear out already it's okay we
haven't gotten ready to go
i think you're ready to go you're going
to talk about some ghosts
we're going to talk about those ready
let's talk about world war ii
that's that's all kind of i saw the
queen talk about i saw the queen bear i
remember that [ __ ]
it's a big it's about i know right where
it is yeah
i've been on it still there it's a hotel
kind of and so you can go there like
paranormal groups and stuff although
i've heard
that it's not a real big money maker but
i guess like the city owns it or the
county owns it and they just kind of
like run it as a museum and hotel and
whatnot
there's a place my mom took me to when i
was a little kid where you can walk
across the thing and there's like
it's somehow under water i don't
remember exactly how it went
you can look over the side of the boat
at a display of a diver
underneath the water and you can see him
there it scared the shadow of me when i
was a kid yeah
it's enclosed but it's also
has something to do with under the water
it's been a long time well they took out
scary
when they converted the boat from a boat
to like a
it's like a hotel a hotel yeah they
actually took out
three of the four propellers but they
left the one propeller i think it's made
of bronze and it's really really big
and they left it there and they kind of
cut a hole in the hole so you could see
it better
that's what it looks like yeah thing
around so so people could like go and
they've made a walkway so you can go and
look
huge propeller underneath the water yeah
yeah it was spooky with lights shining
on it i've seen pictures of it and then
they had a fake
diver with you know the old [ __ ]
diving bell type helmet yeah
and he's there next to it with [ __ ]
bubbles coming out of his [ __ ] helmet
you know but it's not a real man
but it's just to give you scale so you
know how big that [ __ ] propeller is
yeah and it scared the [ __ ] out of me
you know there's a little kid
i didn't want to you know when you look
in the water the dark black water and
under the water yeah [ __ ] that i still
have nightmares
nightmares of being underneath the ocean
and the whale goes by even
and the eye goes by and right just like
the [ __ ] [ __ ] at disney world that's
what twenty thousand leads twenty
thousand leagues
even though you're like literally like
three inches under the water that's
right
you were deeper but once you were like
yeah it seemed like you were underwater
because it made it feel like oh we're
going so deep and like and then like
you'd go and then there was like a big
[ __ ] squid eye and you're what oh
that
but i love that ride i wanted even
though it scared the crap out of me i
wanted to go on
yeah over and over it inspired many
nightmares in me
me too and underneath the goddamn water
and that yeah that thing in the in that
thing in the
in the queen mary was i'd see i think
even scarier
because it was bigger well and it should
be said too
that that propeller perhaps
um maybe really cut up some people okay
all right so i don't know if it was that
one in particular
but it's it's likely just it says is
there a movie audience
yeah there is there's a whole um uh
there was a history channel documentary
has there been like a fictionalized
movie about him
i don't know maybe but i recommend not
like a real big
history channel documentary i think it's
called being evil
and that's not evil it's e-v-e-l being
evil
and that was a good one there's a real
good documentary about it
it's probably up it's probably up on
youtube you can watch it for free
green death says where is the queen mary
ship it is actually in long beach
california
at the moment it was built in scotland
originally
but uh yeah it's in long beach now and
you can go and stay there it's a hotel
as far as i know
you can still stay there because like i
said a lot of
i mean the queen mary is kind of
considered
one of the most haunted locations in the
us
so tons of like ghost hunters have been
there
like psychics paranormal like any all
ghost hunter groups
and they have like um a tour called the
ghost and legends tour
i watched earlier somebody on youtube
had put up like a three-part like they
went through the ghosts and legends tour
like on the queen mary i don't it was
like a few years ago
and they put it up on youtube in like
three parts so that was kind of
interesting like hearing the guy
talking about all the [ __ ] but the thing
about it though is that
one thing i didn't know was that the
queen mary was actually owned by disney
for a time
like in the 70s and 80s i think until
1992
and um they kind of wanted to make it
i think they were the ones that brought
the spruce goose there if i'm not
mistaken
um just because a lot of people weren't
staying at the queen mary and they were
like well we need something else
like so we need this whole like complex
so people will come to it so they put
the spruce goose there
and then they kind of like amped up
the ghost story [ __ ] in the queen mary
and added like special effects and like
all these kind of like music and like
sound effects and [ __ ] like that
green dust ass where is the cream there
i just heard i already answered it
they said long beach yeah beach yeah
so yeah let's talk a little bit okay so
the rms
queen mary rms standing for royal mail
service which is what they
called those particular ships at the
time so this was a ship that was
much bigger much faster uh
than the titanic it was a thousand
feet long uh more give or take you know
so it was built in well it started to be
built in 1930
um at the john brown shipyard in clyde
scotland
now between 1931 and 1934 because of the
depression
um they actually like held off on
building it for
you know those three years but then
afterward they got
back on it and finished it up
it made its maiden voyage on may 27 1936
now for the next three years the queen
mary was kind of considered
the creme de la creme of
oh thank you tim thanks tim um
of like you know transatlantic travel
because it was i mean it was a
luxury liner in every [ __ ] sense of
the word there was kind of there was a
first class as second class and third
class
but one of the things about the queen
mary that was interesting was that
even if you were like in third class
like if you're one of the plebes
um you still got really really good
service you didn't get all the good
[ __ ] that the first class passengers got
obviously
but you didn't get like stuck down in a
broom closet either like the you
actually did
get a really nice like experience and
the ship kind of got known for
being this really nice way to travel
like across the ocean
you know what i'm saying and like i said
they kitted it out with art deck
like it had [ __ ] two swimming pools
it had like theaters it had like all it
was [ __ ] fabulous
right yeah all the best [ __ ]
they had all these celebrities um that
would
you know go back and forth across do the
trans-atlantic crossing
you got duke and duchess of windsor at
the time clark gable
greta garbo mary pickford
george gershwin ira gershwin and sir
winston churchill
who every time that he had to go across
the atlantic he
always went on the queen mary and he had
his own little office on there
i believe his desk is still there and
he's
supposed to still haunt the place
nowadays like people say they can still
he
like smell his cigar smoke and like he's
been seen a couple of times i don't know
if i believe that or not but like some
people have said
that he's that they've like either seen
him or heard him like mumbling because
he um actually signed the
the whole order like for d-day on the
queen mary
but he was like reportedly he was like
real upset about it he's like oh man all
these people are going to die and [ __ ]
like that but we need to do it because
you know um and he was like real
conflicted about it so some people have
said that oh well
that like made such an impression that
it kind of like leached into the ship
and like it's still there so
so like i said for three years it was
like this real big luxury liner
went back and forth many times um you
know from
england to new york now then world war
ii breaks out
and just like everything else no one was
traveling luxury line or anywhere
because everyone was like focused on the
war effort am i making it
so yeah yeah because that one's kind of
bottom line with apple juice how about
that okay yeah we're at orange juice
oh what'd you do okay
i don't know what he's doing he'd make
like a weird noise over there
so um at this stage uh the queen mary
and she also had a sister ship uh the
queen elizabeth
they basically were like okay well we
need to make the ship into a troop
uh transport transport so they pull it
off the luxury liner circuit if you want
to call it that
and they pull out like all the
nice luxury [ __ ] they take out all the
[ __ ] everything that's like nice
about the ship
and they basically make it into um
you know something more suited to
carrying troops across they build like
hospitals on there they build like all
kind of like troop
like bunks and rooms and everything and
they painted the outside gray
um at this point it became known as the
gray
ghost um so
originally the capacity when it was a
luxury ship the
the capacity of the ship was actually
2410
um but during this time when they were
making it like uh troop transport
um they upped the capacity to 5500.
so they made like a lot of rooms with
like thank you see how that tastes with
like double decker uh
bunks and [ __ ] like that so more troops
could like uh
be on board the ship
now what end up happening so
the queen mary actually went back and
forth across the atlantic many times
during world war
ii um now the ship was actually very
very
fast and normally when it crossed
the ocean uh it was so fast
and it would usually swim like in kind
of a
like swim it would usually like go in
like a zigzag formation
formation to keep from like attracting
the attention of the u-boats it also had
like degaussing and stuff like that on
the
deck as most ships did at the time so
they couldn't be seen
uh so it so it would kind of like go
back and forth
many times and evaded u-boats
however there was one really really
terrible
uh thing that happened in 1942 which a
lot of people point to is saying maybe
this is one of the reasons why the ship
is
purportedly so haunted
now in october of 1942
even though the queen mary usually
traveled without escorts
sometimes it had some other boats that
were escorting it
now like i said she would kind of go
zigzag
to avoid u-boats and so the uh
the ships like accompanying her would
also have to zigzag
but the problem was that the ships going
alongside were usually not as
fast and perhaps not as
quick to react like to whichever way the
queen mary was
zigging or zagging at the time so
there was this ship called the hms
kurakoa now i've also seen it called the
curacao
i'm not sure which one is correct but
i'm going with uh
the majority on this one uh that say
kurakoa
just like that's on the wikipedia page
that's on like the bbc page that's on
the world war two
history page so whatever so
i let one cat out pookie is still in the
little bowl
is she really stupid she's not usually
sleeping at this time of day well she's
awake but she's just sitting in a damn
bow
she's just like ah maybe she feels lazy
today she gotta because she should be
asking me to go out
yeah she usually likes to go outside
maybe it's too warm for her it just got
dark
i don't know what the deal is just
giving you guys a pookie update
that's a cookie update that's what she's
doing yeah like i said usually
once it gets dark she's like she thinks
time goes out that's how
i gotta go kills frogs yeah she didn't
kill him she just like
tries to she tries to but they're just
like no
you remember that do you remember that
time this is apropos nothing but do you
remember that time that beijing was
trying to catch a frog
and that it jumped on like the back of
like one of the outside chairs like on
the
on the porch and then it jumped like on
her butt or like on her
flank yeah and she didn't know where it
went to she was so confused she was like
looking around go there was a frog right
here well that was the second time first
time remember when the frog jumped on
her when we first moved here and she
screamed and ran
well that too yeah that was that was
funny too but the yeah the second time i
was thinking of the second time where
the frog like jumped on the chair and
then he jumped like
i was like wow that's a pretty smart
frog and she was just like
where the [ __ ] did the frog go she
didn't know that it jumped on her yeah
the frog was like
florida's filled with these little green
tree frogs little tree frogs little tree
frogs they jump around on you
they look like little geckos like that
little thing from geico that's what they
look like
good guys a little body they're super
cute and if they get in they die
yeah air conditioning it dries them out
yeah it's ridiculous
which is why which every time like if
you can tell though because pookie
thinks she's slick and everything but
if she comes in off the porch and you
let her in and she immediately goes
well i don't have anyone she like runs
into the living room then you know that
she probably has something like hidden
in her mouth and you have to like run
after her and go what do you have and
you have to like open her mouth like
that she's got a lizard or a frog in
there but
like what i just i brought in to play
with but yeah
so all right so this escort ship the
curacao
is zigzagging alongside the queen mary
which obviously is
many times larger now no one is
quite sure later when they did like all
the investigation and everything they
determined that the captain of the queen
mary was not at fault
and that maybe the captain of the
curriculum maybe was because they
weren't really looking
because whatever the reason they were
too close
to the queen mary they were way closer
than they should have been whether it
was because
people were like oh we need to take
pictures because the ship is so big
which is
something that some people have put
forward or whether they were just too
close because
they didn't know what they were doing
what ended up happening was that this
little
much smaller ship um
was essentially cut in half by the queen
mary
and the queen mary just kept on trucking
because there's nothing
you can do at that point i mean that's
kind of like because
um basically i think the the rule was
that look we're in the atlantic ocean
there's german u-boats like all around
like looking for us we can't like dick
around
and like wait and like rescue people
that we hit like just we just have to
keep going because
we don't want to get so it's not worth
the risk but that's what they were
saying
yeah so even that so it was shitty but
it's like
no they basically cut this ship in half
and then just kept on going
and uh many of the dudes 337 guys
on the kurakoa were killed um
they either drowned or they were chopped
up by the propellers
or something well stopping wouldn't help
they would have died anyway mostly
that's
yeah well and that's what they were
saying it's terrible but that's
like maybe a couple of them would have
made it but i mean some of them did live
and depend on how many it depends on how
cold the water is
you'd be dead in 15 minutes and it might
take 30 minutes to damn [ __ ] slow the
ship down and come back and get you
i think that's good yeah i mean it seems
it seems cold-hearted yeah you gotta
understand
what numbers mean yeah all right
it was it was the water cold well yeah
it was the north atlantic oh north
atlantic oh you're dead within 15
minutes
yeah so no just if you're in the water
you're and it was wartime in war time
you're dead
by the time it takes that boat to come
back and get you you'd be
long dead that's about 20 years well and
that's kind of the calculation that they
were making no one was happy about it
obviously
so they had pretty it was a terrible
accident so they had a standing order if
somebody goes over
or if can you hit something keep going
you just that's what they said
you can't help them you can't can't and
that's the thing
it's it's unfortunate but
them's the brakes like i said yeah and
if you're in a dinghy
somebody else can come get your ass yeah
but
i'm not sure entirely i mean the hms
kuroko was not a tiny boat but it was
many times smaller than the queen mary
was obviously
yeah it was just it was supposedly an
escort boat and like i said i think the
investigation afterward
proved that it was essentially the
kuriko's fault
you know if anyone could be faulted just
because they were too close
to the larger ship they shouldn't have
been that close to it um
so yeah so we got down here in the
comments section we must have some ex
semen or something down there talking
about the virtues of zigzag
or serpentine well i was talking about
that earlier because that was like a way
that they would like avoid the uv they
seem to know what this is i don't know
maybe these are yeah
it's zigzagging yeah i know exactly what
it is yeah that's what they're trying to
do
so well and i talked about it there you
go but so
yeah so i was reading this is that drink
is it good yes it was delicious i'm
gonna put some tequila and apple juice
in a bit
that will probably work out yeah sure
let me see what it's like
yeah i've never done it i'll have to
give that a name we'll put that in the
cookbook
and the cookbook is coming along i'm on
page i mean i'm doing all the layouts
i'm doing
10 pages of layouts a day you're right
it's what this might go back and we'll
start
i actually did 12 pages today so yeah
she tried to get me on a dry run and
start talking about recipes and [ __ ]
it doesn't it's not good like that i
have to have a visual representation of
what we're talking about
yeah and what the mood is and what the
background should be you know what i
mean and i'll get more in the mood and
i'll
make i can make some commentary and we
can tweak some of those recipes
yeah yeah because the recipes are all
gonna be pretty standard there's a
couple little modifications i'll make
it's gonna be a cool book you guys are
gonna like it i think it's gonna look
nice
i mean i'm happy with that jenny's doing
most of the heavy lifting though she's
one putting a super structure into that
we we probably need if some better
pictures of a few things but
other than that it's going to be good i
think it'll look good i saw a vegan
black metal chef's book and [ __ ]
get that down jenny show them vegan
black metal [ __ ]
okay i can't my legs are asleep oh [ __ ]
goddamn i'm kicking [ __ ]
which one is it it's the it's the one
that's kind of sticking out around
this one
it's gonna be the quality is gonna be
about like that yeah
like i said i'm making it a hard back
too yeah it's going to be a hardback
okay but yeah but this is the other one
that she did
this is great cookbook black metal shops
yeah
so we're talking you know we're real
we're [ __ ] we know what we're doing
all right jenny's the [ __ ]
we know you know we're doing jenny's
[ __ ] it's going to be really good i mean
most of the time i kind of
i i at least pretend like i know what
i'm doing she used to work for some of
the biggest [ __ ] liquor companies in
the goddamn world doing all their
[ __ ] graphic design
okay you know what you're doing that was
one of the best jobs i ever
yeah they had a bar in the office
[ __ ] a genius i am thank you
genius at what she did what she what you
do not a genius at what i do
what i do is you're only a genius at
like
other than that you're a dumbass no i'm
not saying that
yeah i'm not saying that what are you
talking about i'm trying to [ __ ] put
on a goddamn [ __ ]
this is entertainment we got people
working and i'm entertaining working
people and stuff and then people
laying around in their bedrooms drinking
and it's saturday yeah
saturday it feels like we're laying
around well this isn't our bedroom this
isn't our office
we're in the studio the office is the
studio
yeah matter of fact i'm going to change
some [ __ ] back here you guys are going
to like it you're going to see him
he's going to rearrange re-ran some [ __ ]
bring my robots down i got some really
[ __ ] cool robots some of our
my friend made some of them who owns a
company called hl pro out in japan
i'm gonna bring them down here [ __ ] and
then uh
and i'm gonna set up something here for
jenny i'm gonna re do a little bit of
the lighting i think i'm gonna redo some
of that
we're gonna say remember that [ __ ]
some of those effects we're gonna get
some effects in here i think
like the one that i put in the bedroom i
put some sexy ass lighting in the
bedroom it is pretty sexy it's green and
blue
green and blue lights and it's like it's
almost like a watershed
kind of like if you yeah you know what i
mean like if you like um if you have
like a
in indoor pool it looks like that like
at night it looks kind of like it looks
like that it shines up on the [ __ ]
on the ceiling yeah kind of like uh
that's nice out of that [ __ ] sequel
to blade runner yeah they're [ __ ]
wallace's [ __ ] remember he had all
that damn [ __ ]
water reflections [ __ ] is sexy as [ __ ]
well it's
it's very like relaxing yeah because
it's like nature
kind of yeah nature inside the house
it's nature inside the house
it's like plants but you don't have to
water it um so yeah
so that shitty thing happened and done
says she's working
and it and it's sunday morning where
she's at and she's entertained
we'll see there you go that's all we're
trying michael schaefer says i'm in my
garage getting ready to play some
out tecmo super bowl 1968
season i don't know what that is that
must be uh some kind of video game
techno sounds like i don't remember that
i don't know what it is
tila says we're in our living room
watching on the big screen tv oh my god
oh [ __ ] please don't look at me on the
big screen
tv like that that would be tila and her
husband because i think she's saying
she's making me see all my pores and
stuff
[Laughter]
you're like look at my nose and that's
it oh i'm not into it but yeah so
um so yeah the disaster with the uh
curacao
is supposedly like so that's why like
some people have reported and like i
said
allegedly allegedly some people have
reported being on the
ship or it's not really a ship anymore
technically
and hearing like a bunch of people
like a bunch of dudes screaming and like
a bunch of like scraping sounds and
stuff like that
so some people have said that that's
even though it didn't technically happen
on the ship but the ship
caused all those people to die so
that's another thing that a lot of
people are reported because some people
now
what i've read because i read a book
earlier today
called ghost of the queen mary the
haunted america series
uh which actually if you have kindle
unlimited uh it's free
as an ebook to read just a pro tip if
you want to read it
i read it last night and this morning
and um
they were talking about um how some
people had
heard this noise like like heard all
these people screaming and heard all the
scraping and stuff like that like so
vividly that they thought that they
thought the ship
was sinking even though it's not a ship
anymore like so they thought the hotel
was like sinking into the harbor i guess
because it was like so vivid but um you
know like i said i'm making no
claims to like the reality of any of
this stuff a lot of people have reported
like supernatural [ __ ] on here
but i'm not i'm i'm not taking a stance
on that one way though because i've
never been there i don't know
you know so i'm not saying you've been
there did you feel anything weird when
you were in there no well i was a little
kid
okay i'm trying to think what year that
was
78 70 and probably like 78
so i was about nine yeah and um
it was it was overwhelming because
everything seems very big
it's a huge ship and
it's massive inside it like you said it
was kind of like a just a hotel
yeah but when there's shops and
restaurants yeah shops
kind of like a mall right but then when
i went out along that walkway where you
had the enclosed area and saw the
[ __ ] propeller
that [ __ ] scared me it was [ __ ] i
can see that that would scare me too
yeah
because then it was like something out
of disneyland because like i said
anything like that
yeah you're not under water but you're
looking into the water right
yeah because they wanted it so you could
see the color and you can see the
propeller the water is very steel still
so you can see into the water and you
can see
the bottom of the [ __ ]
you can see the ground of the harbor the
harbor yeah and that was
pretty [ __ ] spooky it was enclosed so
you can't see the sky
it's black it's dark yeah but then it's
lit
underneath the water on the damn pillar
and it's just kind of when you're a kid
very eerie and overwhelming that
propeller is huge and it's underneath
the water
and they got a little fake man who's man
size in the damn diver outfit
next to that propeller and it just i saw
a photograph of it online you guys can
look it up
it's out there that would have scared me
too i'm telling you and it didn't look
as impressive in the photo but when
you're
eight nights yeah when you're a little
kid that would absolutely have scheduled
whoa
and along the lines of like you said
something out of disneyland like out of
that [ __ ] underwater ride
well and disney owned it for a while oh
they did okay
um so they added some because originally
like in the 70s
they actually had plans to kind of build
like a whole ocean themed like
theme park around it um but it ended
up that they were just kind of like they
thought it wasn't economically viable so
they said [ __ ] it and then like long
beach ended up buying it up or
like maintaining it well you could but
disney did own it for a while you could
go
they had the lease rather it smelled
like salt water and it was cold
you know what i mean it had that ocean
smell
but i don't think it had i don't think
it was open to the ocean i think it had
a wall
that went all the way down to the bottom
of the dock i'm not sure been a long
time
yeah i mean something like that like i
said that
would have freaked me out the that
[ __ ] ride at disney world because i
grew up in florida that's disney world
um not disneyland that was california
um you know the 20 000 leagues ride that
used to scare me yeah
and you know what else used to scare me
i had well even though it used to scare
me but
i was fascinated by it nonetheless
because i like things that are scary
i had this book that my i think my
grandfather gave it to me because i
wanted to be a veterinarian when i was
younger
and he gave me this book called the
fishes i might still have it someplace
it might be in the attic
and it had um there was one picture in
particular that really scared me
it was a sand shark but it was like a
close-up of its face
and i don't know if you guys know like
sand sharks and i've seen them in real
life because there's a lot of them like
off of the shore of daytona beach where
i grew up and i used to go to the beach
all the time and you know i've seen like
little ones like around my legs and
stuff
but they have they're not super
aggressive but they have these teeth
that are like [ __ ] they're all [ __ ]
up they're like kind of like all
crooked and they're all like so they
look horrifying
and there was a picture of one that was
like a close-up and every time like i
went through that book
like i'd i knew what page it was on and
i would like go to the page and i'd just
be like oh i don't want to turn oh my
god and i would like freak out
also there was another thing where they
had these pages that would all fold out
and it showed like the different levels
of like all the different types of fish
that were at different like depths
of the of oceans and rivers and whatnot
and when you would get to like the
bottom part like the very deepest part
of the ocean it had all those [ __ ] up
looking fish like angler fish and all
those ones that had like all the
bioluminescence and all that [ __ ]
hanging off their heads and they were
all like super ugly and everything
that that page really freaked me out as
well
but i was like obsessed with it at the
same time yeah you know what i mean like
anybody that's like into horror or
anything like that you get that it's
like it's scary and you don't want to
look at it but then you
you kind of still do yeah you know so it
was kind of like that kind of thing hey
i just want to ask a question
i don't know if jair is out there also
known as
khan often i thought i saw his name
earlier i gotta consult with mexico
i'm putting a shout out to mexico he's
consulting with mexico consulting with
mexico about tequila
does tequila and apple juice work
together
go ahead and come back with me all right
green dust says a jellyfish wrapped
around my area
as a kid oh man oh [ __ ] my balls were
stung
1987. they're me that movie the island
oh
when in jail they put that jellyfish on
their little head
yeah that sucks matter of fact i was
taylor did you see the island because
she was asking about that
remember on the island with michael
caine
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] fire man cocaine
michael
[ __ ] the dude that's one drink away
from whipping your
ass yeah yeah i do it's like a scary he
scared me my whole [ __ ] life as a kid
i thought he's gonna whip my ass him and
that other british dude
oliver reed oliver reed was about right
well like i said
if we if we had our druthers we could go
back in time
i was intimidated and buy both oliver
reed and michael kane
several drinks and then have them fight
each other yeah
the thing is about oliver reed is by all
accounts
charming dude charming dude and fun to
drink with
and got into a lot of trouble and [ __ ]
but it was fun he did get in
uh yeah he got a lot he was the kind of
dude that get drunk down in l.a take his
clothes off [ __ ] walk down the street
see i don't have a problem with dudes
like that you do [ __ ] like that
that's fine and uh popular with the
ladies every day you're having a good
time
you're not hurting anybody no you know
he's out of control though as long as
you're not going around
those dudes grabbing people's titties
they're like rabbits like as long as
you're not
you just go walk down the street that
was the 70s though you could do that
fine if you were [ __ ] michael reed or
if you were if you read or michael king
we're gonna get a [ __ ] computer
program to merge those two faces
together and make a shirt called michael
reed grabbing [ __ ]
that's gonna be the name of it because
back in the 70s
being one of those two dudes you
probably could
the way the 70s was yeah i guess down in
l.a
i think those dudes are popular popular
yeah i think they were very popular they
were bad men man [ __ ] these women like
bad men
to a degree yeah i think they did that's
when they got money and they're on
[ __ ] the silver screen back in the
70s
yeah yeah i think they did like i said
two would agree i think those dudes were
very popular
yeah rebecca says we have this box
jellyfish and
i remember growing up in daytona every
now and then you would go down to the
beach
and there'd be like a whole bunch of
like dead jellyfish
like all over or dead or dying jellyfish
like all over the sand
and like i always remember my mom being
like don't touch them don't touch them
because like a lot of them are still
alive or they can still sting you and
[ __ ] like that which like used to
[ __ ] freak me out
the ones that were all like bubbly you
know what i mean yeah
horrifying tina said they're going to
watch the island they re-watched conan
they loved it yeah
[ __ ] conan i don't know tina did you
check did you see
all those [ __ ] messages that john
that john millions are [ __ ] giving
you
about the riddle of steel and [ __ ]
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you
the secret to the riddle of steel
okay i don't know if you're ready for
this while you're doing that can i pee
well go ahead okay i'm gonna [ __ ]
tell you guys
all right conan's dad
shows him the sword and says the [ __ ]
krom
wanted us to figure out the [ __ ]
riddle of steel and this here
you can trust you could trust this sword
but later on that sword breaks you can't
trust that sword
then later on after that you got [ __ ]
mississippi [ __ ] of course you
know
james earl jones okay afro irish
[ __ ] that he is
okay he comes out in the form
of dosa doom and says yeah i know all
about the riddle still
you know you want to know it don't you
boy and he goes let me tell you the
riddle of steel
because steel isn't strong flesh is
strong and then he [ __ ]
the girl jumps and he goes that's the
riddle riddles deal
they're both wrong later on
conan takes that broken sword and cuts
his head off so even a
broken sword can cut flesh
all right so what was the riddle of
steel
the real esteem was this weapons are not
strong
they will fail you flesh is not strong
that will also fail you what is strong
is
will the will to act
you could be the baddest [ __ ] in
the world with the best weapons in the
world
if you don't do anything then you ain't
[ __ ] you gotta do
something that's what that's the answer
to the riddle of steel
okay go ahead well that was good timing
yeah pookie is still
in the bowl she's sitting in there like
looking at me with one paw hanging out
like hey
yeah i don't know she's being weird
today
all right so world war ii ends
um during the war the ship had carried
more than 800
000 troops there's a great picture if
you google it
of the queen mary with like i don't even
know how many troops it
is but it's just like people just
covering
like the top three decks there were like
so many
people and also they also um transported
like prisoners of war
so it's like all kind of [ __ ] going on
on this ship
um like i said it had a big uh you know
it had a big role in like d-day
it was pretty much every major thing
that happened like in the allied
campaign in world war ii
like the queen mary was somehow involved
in all of that because it was like
the largest ship the fastest ship um at
the time
and it was it could transport the most
troops so it was used like a lot
and it went back and forth could evade
u-boats never got attacked
never had to shoot their guns never had
to do anything
um also at that point it had uh set the
record for carrying the most people
ever on a floating vessel which was 16
683 people so that's how big
this [ __ ] boat is um after the war
ended they actually used it to transport
um war brides back from
because you know like all the troops
that had like married you know american
servicemen like europeans that had
married american servicemen
so all of the brides and the babies like
22 000
22 000 of them they brought them back to
the us and canada
like on the ship so that was kind of
like um
that was 13 voyages i think like doing
that like going back and forth with the
war brides
now at that stage um you know the
luxury liner just they decided to like
bring that back
to the four so they take it back to
dry dock they put all the nice [ __ ] back
in it
you know refurbish it back which kills
me like how much money that must have
cost like they fixed it back all up
all the stuff that they pulled out of it
before like prior to the war had been
you know it was in storage so they put
it all back in there
all the nice like dining rooms all the
art deco [ __ ] they put all that back in
there
so in summer of 1947
they started doing a weekly service that
went between southampton england
cherbourg france and new york city
and it did that for a while until
the early 1960s now by the time the
early 1960s rolled around
because air travel had become so much
more affordable
for the regular person um luxury
ship travel was no longer a thing
or not as much of a thing so
they were finding themselves the queen
mary was kind of finding themselves they
were still going back and forth across
the atlantic but
they weren't getting like capacity you
know sometimes they'd only have like a
couple hundred people on there instead
of a few thousand
and it was getting to the point where
they knew that you know the end was near
because they weren't getting enough
passengers to like justify like all the
cost and everything because it just
wasn't
people were flying they weren't really
taking ships like they used to
um so they decided for a little while
that they were going to start turning
into like a cruise ship
so in 1963 they started going to like
the bahamas the canary islands stuff
like that but the problem was
that the queen mary had been built in
the 1930s
and it was built specifically um
for the north atlantic so it didn't have
air conditioning it didn't have
particularly good ventilation
um so when it was going to warmer
climates like the bahamas and whatnot
people that were on the ship were a
little uncomfortable
you know what i mean it didn't have like
any outdoor pools it has pools but
they're all like enclosed
it didn't have you know how like cruise
ships nowadays have like the big outdoor
decks with the pools on them it didn't
have that
so it couldn't really compete with newer
cruise ships that were coming out that
had like all the amenities
um so basically it's they were just like
bleeding customers at this point so 1967
um they withdrew the ship from
service now that same year
uh she got sold to the city of long
beach california for 3.45 million
dollars
there was there was an auction because
they were kind of like well essentially
at first i think they were gonna like
put her out for scrap
but then there was kind of like some
could just like oh we should maybe we
should turn into a museum or we should
do something else
so long beach california ended up
winning the auction and they uh
got the ship there now initially they
were like okay well we can either do
like a final journey to long beach like
a final
um cruise there like with passengers to
kind of pay for the transport
to long beach or you guys have to pay
like the transportation costs to get
there like with no
passengers on there there still has to
be a crew obviously and they
crew have to get paid um so they opted
to go the passenger route
now the last voyage that they did
was a little bit of a [ __ ] show um it
kind of
ended up going because they had to go
around cape horn and like i said it
wasn't really equipped to deal with
hot weather because it was a north
atlantic ship largely
so all of the passengers that were on
the final journey were kind of like
pissing and moaning about how hot it was
um
several people had heat related
illnesses heat stroke
uh things like that one dude died from
heat stroke actually one of the cooks in
the kitchen
he ended up dying um several people like
because it
had several ports like it went to um i
think it went to las palmas went to uh
you know a couple of went to chile
somewhere like on the way around
and uh people kept getting off like at
every
stop like the richer passengers were
like [ __ ] this we're going to like an
air-conditioned
hotel like we're not putting up with
this crap like some people got off and
then like later they told the media oh
the ship was full of rats and roaches
and stuff like that which they didn't
actually find any evidence of so it
might have just been i don't know people
complaining like
people that give a shitty yelp reviews
nowadays but
you know it it just wasn't uh a real
good experience and the media kind of
like i was saying the media jumped on it
but they were just kind of like oh you
know here the
here she comes like into long beach and
it's like her final voyage is like a
voyage of shame because everyone was
like pissing and moaning about how hot
it was and they couldn't like [ __ ]
take it
and people kept getting off at every
stop so
but eventually it got to long beach
california there was a big celebration
like there's like planes going over like
dropping like flowers and [ __ ] on the
deck and whatnot
so it was like a big deal now when they
had to so what they did was they put it
in long beach harbor
and they had to essentially make it so
that
um it wasn't a ship anymore it was like
a building so they had to
they took out all of the engines they
took out all they took out the boiler
room
they took out three um as i mentioned
earlier they took out three of the uh
propellers
but they left one in there just because
it was big and impressive and they
wanted people to like look at it so they
wanted to turn into like a maritime
museum also a hotel they wanted to kind
of build like a whole
kind of attraction around it so
that sort of came to pass it wasn't as
successful
i think as they were hoping but
in the ensuing years it did become
a big um attraction for particularly for
ghost hunters paranormal
you know people are into paranormal
stuff because it very quickly got the
reputation
that it was super super haunted
so finally now that we're almost two
hours into the [ __ ] let's
start talking about some of the ghosts
that are supposedly haunting
the queen mary so
i've seen um on various paranormal
websites i've seen
estimates if you can estimate this type
of thing
i've seen estimates of between 150
uh to up to 600 ghosts
walking around in this [ __ ] whether
that's true or not i don't know
the um the book the ghost of queen mary
says it's 600 but that was like
according to one psychic that
kind of went there was like oh man
there's like spirits all over which okay
now admittedly the queen mary was the
site of
at least 49 reported deaths
there have allegedly been some other
deaths that were maybe covered up
i don't know if i believe that or not so
that might have added to the total as
well
like i said there was the whole thing
with the kurakoa where 337 people
ended up getting killed because of the
accident
so there's that whole thing going on um
you know
and during the war like i said they were
transporting um you know prisoners of
war
some of whom might have died on board as
well
so there's a lot of history behind it so
i can see like why
it might be uh super haunted
now one of the most
i was like he came in and he said i was
like i thought you went to get a drink
what are you
doing he doesn't have a drink in his
hand so one of the most
haunted probably one of the most famous
stories about the queen mary
is about hatch door
13. we're finally talking about the
ghosts what no what happened was is that
i had to let i was like yeah what took
you so long i had to find the cat's
collar so i could let
pookie out yeah cause she's not allowed
to go to the pool without a collar
i mean she needs her a little bit she's
gotta have clothes on for you gonna go
outside that's what we always said we're
like we gotta put your clothes on
but she knows yeah okay now hold on one
second i was talking with tila
about conan and i'm gonna point
something out about conan not only the
riddle of steel
but there was some [ __ ] about the
necklace in the eye of the serpent and
the wheel of suffering
conan was [ __ ] born on the wheel of
suffering what they're talking about is
we're talking about
buddhism in the wheel of suffering
it's about desire there's always a wheel
all right it's a cyclical thing in
buddhism you want things
you get things you're satisfied by
things
and then you become disappointed by it
and it's replaced by another desire
you're constantly wanting things getting
them [ __ ] getting sick of them
and [ __ ] getting something else it's
and it's the constant
wheel of [ __ ] dis
dissatisfaction so coleman
conan is in the [ __ ] it's symbolic of
life
you know you're never satisfied with
constant disappointment conan's in the
[ __ ] pit
early on in his career first of all the
drudgery of it he's pushing the [ __ ]
thing he's getting stronger and then
they put him in the pit to fight
other ones all right and in the pit the
narrator
his [ __ ] one of his father figures i
forgot his name the sorcerer he goes
conan found his own self of worth
his own sense of self-worth he mattered
all right what they're saying is is that
through the wheel of suffering
eventually
you can find out that what you do
matters
and that'll help you take action in life
because what you do matters all right
but that's not the [ __ ] solution to
everything
dulce dum and his boys had [ __ ]
captured the eye of the serpent
and they had a whole cult of women that
worshiped them
in mythology this goes all the way back
to the goddess asherah
and in the garden of eden in the [ __ ]
old testament
the serpent is always a female symbol
because it's an
egg which is female and it's in the
ground and it comes out a serpent which
is male
and then it goes back into an egg into
the ground so it's the male
and female [ __ ] cycle also women are
evil
well no that was actually that was not
the original story
no just kidding okay valeria
told him let's get out of this life
we'll [ __ ] be happy
we can have a family or something and we
don't have to worry about this [ __ ]
conan goes no no no i need vengeance
later on she dies on the mission she
sacrificed herself for a [ __ ] conan
and he realized he there's a scene where
he takes the wheel of suffering necklace
off it's just like when
he takes it off and then he puts her
necklace on which was the stolen
eye of the serpent asherah and what that
[ __ ] represents was
is it conan realizing that his only way
to get out of that life is to adopt a
family life and live
and achieve immortality through children
through the reproductive process that's
what it symbolizes
okay so that that's only one of the many
things
that was hidden in [ __ ] conan john
milius and oliver stone who wrote that
[ __ ]
they are [ __ ] geniuses and me being
me loving religion and mythology that's
just that's my favorite movie
that conan is definitely my favorite
well see we writers aren't dummies it's
like definitely we know all the [ __ ]
about like [ __ ] mythology we know all
the [ __ ] about we've all read joseph
came but we all know exactly
it's very much like like a joseph
campbell type story we know all about
the symbols
it is conan is the the [ __ ] blueprint
is a blueprint on how to be a man and
how to be a woman
and a good example of it if you ask me
that's just my opinion but i believe it
to be true
based on my experiences okay tila
started singing a wheel in the sky and
that's exactly what i was thinking as
well yeah which is really weird because
when that came up i was like oh i was
just
buddhism and buddhism
the wheel or the wheel of suffering is
something you're supposed to escape
you're supposed to reach nirvana which
is an in an enlightened indifference
yeah to the wheel of someone so because
the wheel is kind of like it's it's
the same [ __ ] same [ __ ] differently
right
and emilius's vision the only way out of
that is
by having descendants yeah which is
that's how you're gonna
achieve mortality immortality but
true individual immortality that's not
demonstrated in
in in the movie code in that goes
against nature
you're supposed to die eventually it's
part of the cycle well yeah that's just
how [ __ ] goes
and even yoda says this [ __ ] in [ __ ]
star wars even yoda
back when star wars was good and written
well but yeah
yeah even you he had to get says that oh
yeah so you can't die you're yoda [ __ ]
you know i'm not that strong yeah no
only evil
never dies yeah just ask my mom
i know i know exactly what you're
talking about that whole family
sad right yeah only evil yeah but it
seems to be true which is kind of a
bummer
you know what i mean but yeah so uh
yeah so we're talking about the ghost
you into it yeah yeah yeah okay are you
still like on the conan
tip or he said i pulled the hair out and
peed all over himself from what we don't
i don't know i i don't know
yeah just yeah sheila was saying that
psychic peter james that's what i was
talking about um
actually peter james i think he's passed
away
but the guy that wrote goes to the queen
mary
the haunted america book that i read on
uh
kindle unlimited he was talking about
peter james and that's
i guess peter james went to the queen
mary and that's how he got his gig
on sightings i think was the first show
he was on and then he was on scariest
places later on
um but i think like he got like a lot of
notoriety because of his [ __ ] about
and apparently peter james he was the
one that came up with like
a lot of these ghosts because he was a
psychic he went on there and he was like
saying he communicated
i mean particularly one of the ghosts
that's kind of one of the more famous
ones which is like a little girl her
name is
jackie or jacqueline and he supposedly
has recordings of him like talking to
this little girl
like for like 20 minutes or something
like that you know what i mean which
i don't know i don't know you know what
i mean yeah
but yeah so like i said between i've
seen estimates from 150 to 600 different
ghosts i think peter james was one of
the ones that said the other 600 ghosts
on this [ __ ] which okay
so now the engine room
of the queen mary um this is one of the
more
active areas of the ship now
apparently i don't know if they did some
filming of the poseidon adventure on
here or
i've also heard that like the dude that
wrote the poseidon
adventure had been on the queen mary
and that's where he got the idea well
look
the whole hollywood scene was right
there near long beach
yeah anybody who moved there went to go
see the [ __ ] queen mary was a local
attraction
so i'm sure he was inspired by it i kind
of feel like
that's probably yeah and uh on a side
note people
[ __ ] silver tequila and oran and
apple just don't they don't mix
you don't like it no that [ __ ] you're
doing [ __ ] does it that [ __ ] tastes like
wait you want to try it
no i don't want to try it i don't like
tequila anyway
i'm going to roll with it just because i
have to you know
well once you've had a few drinks it
doesn't really matter what it tastes
like
you know it might be better than that if
i put a little bit of lemonade in there
it needs some tart well all right
we got lemonade we got lemonade right
yeah look at him he's like [ __ ]
he's trying to make it work he's trying
to make it work we have limited in the
fridge
all right so like i said i'm not sure if
they filmed like some parts of the
poseidon adventure on this or if the
dude that wrote the poseidon adventure
was just inspired by
like [ __ ] about the queen mary but so
there's this
very famous uh section of the ship and
it's usually called shaft alley
and there's the very famous hatch door
number
13. now this is kind of confusing
because i've read like a whole bunch of
different
[ __ ] about this particular haunting or
this particular area
one of the most famous stories about
this particular part of the ship and
this supposedly happened
in 1966. yeah a little bit of lemon
worked out
oh okay well there you go i'm glad you
were able to salvage it
yeah just put a little bit of that you
have to dump it out and start you know
what it tastes a little bit like an
energy drink
yeah tammy says can't waste the tequila
you can't
i mean [ __ ] like even if it tastes like
[ __ ] i'm just going to drink it anyway
because
that tastes a lot like booze is
expensive that tastes a lot like a red
bull
that's not a good thing well i think
it's awesome
well you like purple good for you okay
but yeah so
this is the story and like i said i'm
confused about this because there's two
different stories and i don't know if
it's the same dude or not
but okay so the story goes that in 1966
so there are these doors
in the engine and boiler rooms and they
weren't like
they were controlled from the bridge so
it's like if
they were able to be closed they were
watertight like in case water was like
coming in the ship like to keep
water from coming in like [ __ ] up the
engines or whatever so it's like they
would close like automatic so they were
bridge controlled you couldn't control
them from like down in the you know
boiler room or down in the end room
where you were
so apparently there was really bad fog
one night
or there was something going on it was
high waves or whatever so the captain
says hey we need to like shut all the
doors down in
[ __ ] shaft alley which i don't think
they called it them but whatever so it's
like we need to shut all the doors back
that so they closed all of them
now this was like 3 55 in the morning
five minutes later some people go down
there and they find a dude
who was 18 years old he was a crew he
was on the crew
and they found him like smushed in the
door
because the door like i said they were
automatically controlled so they would
like close like i was like bam like that
like really quickly
um and i guess he was either
in there like because i've heard either
somebody like murdered him by like
holding him in there like well the door
was closing
or that he thought he was being like
clever by saying
because apparently among the younger
crew members the younger and dumber crew
members at the time
they were kind of like hey they had like
some weird kind of game of chicken
where when the doors were going to close
like they would hear the alarm
and then they'd be like hey let's see if
we can like jump through the door before
it closes
and like whoever gets the closest like
you're the biggest badass
except this guy like didn't make it this
time
it didn't cut him in half i've seen some
people saying that like oh he was cut in
half
that's not what happened they found his
body
and he was kind of smushed in the door
but he wasn't super [ __ ] up like he
just had like blood coming out of his
nose or his mouth or whatever
and he was still alive but
when they like took him to the hospital
he died like later on because all of his
internal organs were smoshed
you know what i'm saying so he wasn't
cut in half or anything like as grisly
as that
but i so i don't know if it was i'm
assuming it was just an accident i don't
think it was murder
but so this dude is apparently
one of the people that has been haunting
the [ __ ]
now this guy's ghost like i said i'm
confused over
whether this is because i was reading go
so queen mary and he names
two different guys one of the dudes
uh was named john petter and this guy
is supposedly was the 18 year old and
they were playing chicken
and he didn't get out of the way of the
door fast enough when they were playing
the game and ended up getting smushed
whereas this other guy john mckenzie
was supposedly murdered the same like
that everybody hated this dude and
they said hey we're just gonna hold him
in the door like when the alarm goes off
and he's gonna get smushed in there
um so i don't know if this is like the
same dude and they're just like
conflating to
separate occurrences i'm not really sure
but whatever the case uh
this is a very famous haunting many
people have said
that um when they are down in this area
of the ship
shaft alley that they hear somebody
running behind them
they hear somebody whistling um some
people have reported like spots
like greasy fingerprints um that appear
on their faces
um some people have actually claimed to
have seen an apparition
of a dude with a beard that has blue
come rolls on
and this dude apparently looks a lot
like one of the two dudes that actually
did die on the ship
um he's usually just seen like kind of
out of the corner of your eye
um and some people have also reported
saying they saw a dude that looked like
he was dressed kind of like an engineer
kind of outfit and he's like wandering
around in the hall
like down there and he asks people if
they've seen his wrench
damn which to me man
if you're a ghost you're just going to
spend your eternity like
that's like where the [ __ ] is my where
the [ __ ] is that wrench at
well some people it's driving me crazy
some people have
have hypothesized that
some of these ghosts ghosts come might
come in different flavors
all right and one of the versions of the
strawberry flavored some are tequila
flavored
some ghosts might just be kind of like
an echo of the past like an emotional
echo i kind of feel like that's more
likely than
i don't believe in ghosts generally but
i do feel like if they do
exist i think it's kind of more like a
like a tape repeating itself yeah
i don't i don't think they're seen a
pulse i've seen a poltergeist that [ __ ]
is [ __ ] intense as physical
jenny's seen a little bit of it but i
think that comes from a living part yeah
come from a little
now that house that me and [ __ ] eric
moved into after we got out of the army
that might have been a haunted house
that may have been a ghostbeard ghost
like what we're talking about
but it felt like an emotion from the
past
is what it felt like and it affected
everybody that went into it
but it wasn't as strong as a poltergeist
not physically
i think like i said i don't believe in
ghosts generally but i think if they do
exist
i think it's kind of like a stone tape
kind of situation
where some kind of it's just something
that's like
you know there was a there was a lot of
emotion that somehow it printed itself
some kind of a quantum recording that
you can summarize right i think
yeah i think it's that and it might reap
and i don't know if that's true or not
i'm just saying that's probably
to me that seems like the message which
would make more sense that only some
people could access it
yeah because not everybody sees it when
they go because like like a message from
the past and
thousands of people go to the queen mary
all the time and i've seen like a lot of
ghost hunter people that have gone there
and like they didn't see
[ __ ] or they didn't hear [ __ ] but then
some people go there and like see and
hear all kind of things
so i do kind of feel like only some
people can like pick up on that
yeah now on upon my authority
okay my author my author
based upon my experiences i've seen
[ __ ] poltergeist
that is a physical [ __ ] that is a
physical
phenomenon is very [ __ ]
very startling very you know it'll
really change your viewpoint of the
world
that right there i think is a very
different
phenomenon to what a lot of people are
calling ghosts
yeah and i think thank god completely
yeah and i think i've [ __ ]
experienced through that house
zachary asked me about it he was the
first one that said tom but you haven't
told us about the house
the house compared to the to mammoth
mountain poultry guys was [ __ ] weak
ghosts are weak in my experience
i think it's just a recording of the
past
somehow you go into that area and you
have a feeling
that something is bad happens something
bad happened there
and it and it wouldn't surprise me if
it's not just
humans that would be able to access that
maybe animals could access that
that this is a bad place something
happened here
and you might get a few images you know
what i mean
in your dreams because i was living in
that place
that are kind of related to it but it's
emotion it's not
it's not a living creature it's not yeah
it's not like interactive
no that's why i think a lot of the stuff
with the ghost hunter shows without like
talking to these ghosts
waste of time i don't think that that's
necessarily
waste of time in my experience most in
my experience what they're talking about
and
maybe there's something like that but i
haven't seen it in my experience what
they're talking about is they're
accessing emotions from the past
and it and i think you know you say well
how do you explain that
it's something to do with quantum
consciousness or some kind of quantum
recording or something you know i mean
in the fabric of space-time in that area
somehow some kind of trace is left
behind now i'm sounding like [ __ ] mr
halloran
from the shining you are yeah which
there's something to that there is
something to that
okay but so it's something like that
that's what i it in my experience
and i think i have a lot more experience
than the average person
maybe not as much as some of these
investigators that saw a bunch of [ __ ]
you know what i mean but
i saw one poultry guys to one ghost
or one haunting and yeah she didn't
see an action no i didn't see it i was
in a haunted house
it just was a feeling what they called a
haunted house is a feeling
it was a feeling in it and it affected
you
but it was things from the past
yeah it wasn't it wasn't something that
was living in the present although maybe
it felt like it was but i don't think it
was
alex says is it it's actually mammoth
like a woolly mammoth yeah
yeah mammoth mountain mountain yeah
you wrote a book about it man if i can
read it that was some crazy mammoth
mountain poultry guys jenny wrote it
yeah and we've changed it a couple times
to update it and uh the audio book has a
little
more interviewing with me in it well the
audiobook
um we uploaded um
was i think it had like the update of
like the [ __ ] that happened at this
house
because that hadn't happened it hadn't
happened yet when i wrote the book
forgot how many updates we've done to it
just one like the audiobook just has
like an extra chapter
but if you guys buy the all the the the
[ __ ] math mountain poltergeist
audiobook that jenny did what's in that
book is absolutely true i lived through
it
all right that that did happen
i'm i'm [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] i
[ __ ] around a lot i jump
i i joke around a lot i clown
but the story that i told jenny and that
is absolutely true
jenny talked to my aunt and my uncle
when he was alive and they
they were like yeah that [ __ ] did happen
talk to your cousin too a little bit
it was the weirdest [ __ ] thing ever
all right so not everything is
is as it seems there is weird [ __ ] out
there
another one i could vouch for would be
[ __ ] enfield poltergeist
it's an old book guy lying play fair i
had the same thing happen to me
and i really think some of those [ __ ]
sightings from [ __ ] air force pilots
with these ufos i also think that is
real
i think it's some kind of an alien
presence you know but
now this stuff about you know guys from
[ __ ] tennessee
saying that a ufo came down and i had
sex with a beautiful alien woman and
he she she showed me our children [ __ ]
no
i don't believe that but yeah that's a
little silly
no things are things are seen and it's
starting to come out a little bit
so some of the government agencies are
like uh yeah we do see some weird [ __ ]
and you know now the bigfoot thing
when i was a kid i believed more in
bigfoot there could be something like
that alive still
it would be in washington state or
canada well like i said i feel like of
all the paranormal like
panoply of like [ __ ] i kind of feel like
bigfoot is probably the most i'm not
saying i believe in bigfoot i'm just
saying
it's likely it's the it's the most
likely of all the other things
and there's another one out there
because it's just he would just be an
animal and there's
another thing out in indonesia called
oring pendick
and there's been some very credible
people and biologists that have seen the
oring pendick
and the o-ring pen deck would be a small
bigfoot it's kind of red
he's a small foot it's a small foot yeah
but what you're talking about is a
hominid or a humanoid yeah which isn't
weird because it's not that weird they
did exist at some point
right i mean so there may be something
like that still out there
you know so look at like the
quote-unquote hobbits
right now spiritual bigfoots that
teleport around and don't leave
okay that is just dumb just give a [ __ ]
out of here come on
the this this [ __ ] like trying to have
your cake and eat it too it's like look
bigfoot isn't like cool or exotic enough
so now we're going to have him like he's
a ghost and an alien
yeah come on this is a paranormal true
crime
mystery show we do have some [ __ ] to add
to it
i'm a personal witness so is jenny
but there's limits to certain things
there's a lot of [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
hoaxes
there could be an orange pen deck there
could be a bigfoot but it would be
very much up north and there wouldn't be
very many of them and it would just be
another hominid
like a gorilla yeah or something like
that which like i said we know gorillas
exist
right gorillas used to be paranormal
those weren't really proven to the white
man until i think what
that's true that was actually yeah 1890s
something like that i can't remember
offhand it used to be the white man
didn't believe in gorillas oh that never
existed until they captured something
they went
oh okay so it might be a situation like
that but there wouldn't be very many of
them
i think there might be an o-ring pen
deck but this idea of well it's a
spiritual
creature that teleports around that's
why he doesn't leave football that's why
that's what i was going to get to you
got jack
you got jackals saying that they seen
[ __ ] but there's no footprints left
behind
they said well it's spiritual no you
made it up
well or you did the thing about it is
that i feel like
if you're okay if your worldview
and or career is built upon
you um writing books about this thing
you really have to come up with anything
you can come up with
like any excuse you can come up with to
like
say why this thing exists so if somebody
says
hey what about this that and the other
thing you have to have like an answer
for every single thing as dumb as it
[ __ ] sounds
to normal people to people who
believe you and like buy your [ __ ] then
that absolutely sounds like an excuse
because they just want to believe it
which if you want to believe in bigfoot
if you want to believe that bigfoot is
like a [ __ ] alien and he's up there
on the ship with elvis or whatever the
[ __ ] you want to let's just believe that
it's fine
but don't try to like
come out and be like this [ __ ] is like
objective reality because it ain't
but if you want to believe it then
that's up to you you're not hurting
anybody
yeah zack's trying to take me back to
[ __ ] conan
about the conversation conan and subotai
had
about the gods what they're talking
about in there
in that one okay now i'm trying i'm
trying to quote is they're talking about
krom lives in his mountain okay
and subitize god as the sky that lives
above the mountain that his [ __ ] god
was a higher
all right if you actually look at the
characters what you're talking about is
that they're different kinds of warriors
conan is a ground warrior
he's a guy that carries heavy weapons he
doesn't move fast but he has a lot of
power
subutai is a sky warrior he's got arrows
he's small he moves fast and he's
accurate
what you're talking about is you're
talking about the rival what
john milius is talking about is the
rivalry between
infantry like me
okay and fighter pilots
sky warriors and ground warriors they're
talking about that rivalry
but in conan the [ __ ] is settled because
they're all on the same team that's what
that
conversation was about well yeah because
they have different strengths they have
different both of the strengths are
equally valid and they're working
together to complement themselves on the
battlefield
one guy's dominating the ground another
guy's dominating the sky
it's two different gods that's what
they're talking about
that's that yeah and in
some bigfoot right yeah
and and super tight with [ __ ] whip
coden found him chained up outside a
woman's house saying she left me for the
[ __ ] wolves
she was a witch though she was a witch
well all women are witches they're evil
that's what that's what well
we are actually actually that's not what
the story is
that's not what the story says the story
was saying that
some women will destroy you and want you
to give up your soul
for things that's what the witch was all
right
that's what the witch was all right
conan saved that man from the witch and
then they're [ __ ] buddies
then they move on but then conan [ __ ]
meets a good woman
conan meets a good woman she was a good
woman just like him all right
who prom and she promised him eternal
life in terms of [ __ ] ancestors
that that's what they're talking about
there in in that story
millions stone knew what they were
[ __ ] doing all right
they were bros okay they were they were
bros
but that [ __ ] okay they're telling it
from
go ahead laugh they're telling it from
the male perspective
but there's a female equivalent to but
you know what i'm talking about
have you ever saved another woman from a
bad man
every every woman there you go that's
what they're talking about that's what
they're talking about
some men are sorcerers some women are
sorcerers that's what they're talking
about
well yeah how many times have you oh i
can think of a situation i'm not going
to say anything about it
man you got men writing this story you
have men writing this story so they're
going to tell the story to other men
that's what that right they don't get
the the woman perspective
well they do get the word i mean they do
but they're not they're not women so
they don't they're not women so they're
not going to tell it from that story
right that's all it is
that's all it is but like you said it's
the same thing like
we've all like i i feel like probably
every woman in existence has had to tell
one of her
friends sister or somebody um
yeah get rid of that dude right that's
better it's the same thing
you got super tight is out there chained
up and she's like what you do
left me for the wolves you know
and you know you're you're gonna you're
gonna find women as a woman you're gonna
find another
he left me for the wolves you know that
that's that's what that's what they're
talking about
yeah i get that yeah um so yeah
so wow we went like so far man i'm
you need to make me another drink
already all right holy crap
same thing yeah sure i'm gonna get back
to talking about ghosts god damn it what
are you doing
poultry guys knocked it down didn't it
no that was you
all right so okay some other [ __ ] on the
uh
ship other than hatch door 13 which is
very famous
now probably the second most famous area
in the ship are where the swimming pools
are now
one of the swimming pools is still there
um it's been
drained so it's technically not a
swimming pool and it's just like a big
[ __ ] tile
hole at this point uh the other the
second class swimming pool i don't think
is the pool anymore they might have
filled it in at this point i haven't
been there
but um so this is the place where i feel
like most of the paranormal
investigators
even though this isn't necessarily the
most active place historically
this is kind of the place that's gotten
the reputation of being the most active
so this
the pool areas are like the place that
most paranormal investigators will go
to get like some [ __ ] action here you
go let me check the pokey real quick oh
thanks
okay now there have been several
spirits reported around this area
including uh there's one woman actually
there's several women but one woman in
particular that's a very that's quite
famous that has been seen multiple times
she shows up in like a 1930s looking
uh swimsuit and she's like kind of like
wandering around the decks near the pool
now supposedly she even leaves like wet
footprints
like on the floor now something that
might be confusing
is that i'm not sure if disney was the
origin of this or if this was a later
thing
but when they started doing like ghosts
the ghosts and legends tour
on the queen mary they started adding
you know for spice so people would
like get something for their money i
suppose
they started adding like special effects
sound effects all that kind of [ __ ]
they're not saying that it's real
they're not saying oh
it's oh it's ghosts or anything like
that but they're kind of like making it
more like a haunted house type
attraction
so one of the special effects they added
was
wet footprints like appearing on the
floor
in certain areas of the ship now
so some of the [ __ ] if you see like the
wet footprints some of that [ __ ] is fake
like it's special effects
because that's a story that gets told a
lot
um now what i have heard from various
paranormal investigators is that
as like when that happened when they
started doing the fake
wet footprints like the supposedly
real wet footprints of the spirit that
was known for doing that
kind of like got less and less like she
was pissed off about it or something
like she was trying to be like
hey i left you guys in like and now
you're like faking it i'm not
about that so i'm just saying i don't
know if they do it anymore but for a
long time they were doing a show
like in the whole tour and it had a
thing where like you would get a thing
and then
like wet footprints would appear on the
floor and that was totally not real that
was like special effects
but supposedly some people have said
that
that happened for real like before that
and also now that it doesn't do it
anymore as far as i can
like understand so another ghost
that appears a lot um in this area um
you know people have heard like
splashing in the pool even though
there's no water in it anymore
um there's also the spirit of is she all
right yeah
and and um beige came in what'd she do
beige walked in like get the [ __ ] you
know how she is
she's so [ __ ] you guys i know and and
the wind's blowing which means
rain's coming i thought
do you know what like earlier this
afternoon i've
i heard like because i have a wind
there's a window like right there
and i heard like [ __ ] like hitting the
the window like
what are you doing stretching
i thought it was [ __ ] up i thought it
was hailing outside no it's [ __ ]
blowing like crazy i'm hammered man
oh you people have to talk me through
this [ __ ] you're gonna have to talk me
through this [ __ ] you'll be all right
i drank a lot mark says pookie and
beijing should be there in the room with
y'all
no they're outside playing the wind's
blowing like [ __ ] crazy they got to
be out there for that
it was very windy earlier today beige
came in but
beijing will not come in here unless
she's really really lonely yeah you know
what i mean
then she'll come in but even then it's
like grudgingly
i think it's i don't know if she's she's
not that old she's what 11
she's 11. yeah she's old
but um that's not yeah i guess that's
kind of old for a cat
but she is very cranky she's always been
kind of a diva
she's not real affectionate and you know
every now and then she will be but
there has to be certain circumstances
but it's kind of like even if you
try to like pet her like if she's in the
room and you're like oh hey
princess whatever you pet her and she's
like she goes like that
like she doesn't want you to do it and
she like kind of
[ __ ] off yeah she's like that i don't
know she's very [ __ ]
alex said that he's got a friend that
thinks that the national park system was
correct i was gonna say that earlier
but that's some crazy [ __ ] no yeah that
seems like um
a lot of effort to go through just to
cover up one hominid
no they want to find bigfoot i guarantee
i mean they'd make a lot of money if
they found this
see that's what i mean that's what i
don't believe a lot of these conspiracy
theories i'm like think about what
you're saying you were thinking about
that you were saying that there's a
whole entire
national [ __ ] thing with like
hundreds
thousands of employees to hide bigfoot
just
for that one thing no one's gonna do
that no nobody
no i mean that is the stupidest thing
ever that's like i said that's what i
don't believe in conspiracy theories
because there's like there's too many
people that have to be involved it's
like it's
it's not gonna it's not worth it it's
not worth it
so like i said the uh the pools which
like i said are
actually really beautiful if you see
pictures of them it's very like i said
it's art deco
and it's all nice and everything um so
people have reported hearing like
splashing sounds like someone was still
swimming to the pool even though there's
no water anymore
um there's a little girl that's often
seen in this area
like you know with a little teddy bear
in her hands
some people have said that they've seen
like a younger woman in a tennis skirt
walking down the stairs because there's
there's the pool and there's like these
two big
like stairs like that that kind of go
down it's like like i said it's really
nice looking
very classy um but she kind of like
walks down the stairs and then she
disappears behind a pillar
um some people have said in this area
they also saw a woman in a wedding gown
uh next to the pool and then she's like
standing with this little boy that's
kind of like in a little suit
um some people have also said they saw
like a weird like cloud like of like
smoke or steam or something like that
and it kind of comes out of nowhere and
then there's like a little girl and she
has like a blue and white dress on
and then she kind of like appears and
then she goes and then she's gone
um now in the second class pool room
which
as i said is not as far as i know it's
not a pool anymore because
like i said a lot of the [ __ ] that um
when this was a ship you know [ __ ] that
was a pool it's like they
they changed a lot of stuff like into
something else like when it was made
into a museum in a hotel
so a lot of stuff is not what it used to
be so the second class pool
um this is where one of the more famous
ghosts
kind of shows up and this is like a
little girl named jackie or jacqueline
and like i said they talk about this
little girl a lot in the
uh ghost of queen mary book this is
supposedly a little girl
that several psychics have talked to at
length
um there's also another alleged
ghost who might be a teenage girl named
sarah
that is kind of like looking out for her
there's another ghost too in this
uh ship that's just called the lady in
white she doesn't have a name i guess
and um she's also kind of like a mother
figure supposedly
to this little girl they don't know who
this little girl is
now this the little girl jackie
the story goes that she
drowned in the pool like while the ship
was still
like sailing or still a luxury liner now
i will note that as far as i know there
is no record of anybody
drowning in any of the pools during any
of the time
that the queen mary was a passenger ship
doesn't mean it didn't happen sure it
could have been covered up
but i don't know i kind of doubt it so
no one really knows who this little girl
is they only know that that's her name
because like that's what
various psychics have said so supposedly
this little girl like talks to many
paranormal investigators people hear her
like
laughing giggling some people have seen
her if you look at the
ghost of queen mary book there's
actually a picture you saw it earlier
yeah which uh there's it looks like
a very vague looking like little girl
like peeking over the top of like the
staircase
like that goes down to the pool it looks
it looks very much like that amityville
horror yeah that's what i thought it was
like that amityville picture that like
ed and lorraine warren took
like a little kid like peeking out of
the door it does
zach's in there hold on one sec
what's his name zach and michael they're
[ __ ] going on about what i said about
conan
he's going yeah they're saying he didn't
know he's talking about or whatever that
hasn't
do with conan look the [ __ ] sky
warrior and ground warrior
[ __ ] things were
messy they're modern messages they don't
have anything to do with the ancient
world that's not the way
john millius and [ __ ] um
oliver stone saw things they're trying
to give modern messages
to modern people through
i guess you could say mythology all
right it doesn't have anything
in it and [ __ ] michael's right it
doesn't have anything to do with [ __ ]
howard's version of [ __ ] code in
they're very different
that was just milius milius and stone
they even had a different idea about
what time plate
what time this was happening in
stone wanted this to be happening in the
future in a post-apocalyptic world yeah
that's right we talked about that
yeah [ __ ] tens of thousands of years
in the future okay like after [ __ ] got
blowed up right i just thought that
just like teenage caveman right and then
roger corbin and that that story in the
beginning about the gods
losing the [ __ ] riddle of steel on
the battlefield was actually about a
nuclear warfare
you know yeah so i know what i'm talking
about teenage caveman right yeah i know
what i'm talking about
but uh the covenant was supposed to
represent infantry and subutai was
supposed to represent
air force pilots fighter pilots that's
that was the idea
sky warriors and ground warriors go
ahead
which the and the rival rivalry between
the two
okay you got working class guys on the
ground and you got these [ __ ] higher
class guys in the sky
they're very different but they're both
fighting and dying for [ __ ] and they're
both on the same team
that was the [ __ ] idea well like i
said they have different skill sets
exactly because that's what's cool
everybody's got different skills yet
conan was [ __ ]
arnold being played by arnold
schwarzenegger a big [ __ ] with a
sword sometimes an axe
all right and then super tired was
played by a small surfer
in in [ __ ] furs with a bow
alright it was a very different
types of fighters see how they said a
bow and arrow was a much better
weapon because you could get people from
farther away if you were a good
yeah if you're up close you're [ __ ]
and well yeah
obviously right or an
had a sword too but it was a short sword
but you know you just got to pay
attention
to the damn and you got you got to pay
attention to the [ __ ] because i feel
like i'm more of a sniper
yeah type of mentality and remember how
subatai [ __ ] saved conan
in the pit with the [ __ ] with the big
ass [ __ ] snake
yeah conan was [ __ ] fighting it up
close with
axes and swords and super tight back
there when he could shoot like three
arrows
i'm back here i'm totally safe you guys
i'll just get it from back here
right so he was he was in support i got
it covered so his small
size his small size was not a
disadvantage with his style of fighting
that's what they're talking about yeah
like i said everybody's got their own
everybody has their own skills sure
right which that's a nice message
yeah just gotta say all right so
another very uh famous aspect of the
queen mary haunting
is stateroom b340 now i got some [ __ ] to
say about this
but i'm just gonna go with
the [ __ ] that's on a lot of paranormal
websites so
stay room b340 is kind of touted as one
of the most haunted
places on the ship um supposedly the
story goes in 1948
there was a third class passenger who
was british
and his name was walter adamson and he
supposedly
died in the room from
undisclosed whatever um
and then in the 60s apparently people
started reporting
that the room was haunted like people's
covers would start coming off
at night uh like get pulled off them
people started seeing like apparitions
of a dude like standing at the foot of
their bed
and whatnot um some people
even in more recent times have reported
hearing someone knocking on the door in
the middle of night
the lights in the bathroom turn off and
on
the maids at the hotel said that they
keep finding the water
turned on like in the bathroom even when
no one's staying in the room
um you know [ __ ] like they'd make the
bed and then they'd go back in there and
like the covers be all [ __ ] up and
everything like that
now apparently this room was like closed
to guests for a long time but what i
now like i said i don't know if any of
this is true this is paranormal stuff so
it's all very nebulous like i said
but according to the book ghost of queen
mary
the [ __ ] about stateroom b340
anything that they allege happen in that
room
um is probably like misattributed
because they're like look um
stateroom b
was never a hotel room you know what i
mean
it was one of those things when they
were first building it out as a hotel
they finished 150 rooms and then
they discovered that the demand for
rooms was not as high as they were
anticipating
so a lot of the rooms that they were
planning to turn into hotel rooms
they didn't end up turning into hotel
rooms they just like used them for
storage or whatever
so b340 was one of those so
in the whole entire time that this was a
hotel
b340 was never a hotel room however
what i have heard was that there was
another room
uh that was b474
now what i've heard about this room was
that in 1959
supposedly there was a family staying in
this particular room when it was a hotel
and the dude the dad of the family
like [ __ ] flipped out for whatever
reason that
dudes flip out and strangled
his wife and his two daughters and then
shot himself in the head i'm not sure if
this is true
but i've seen it repeated on several
websites
so supposedly this happened in b474
in 1959 and what ended up happening was
that when disney owned the hotel and
they were like
looking to turn this into an attraction
and they were kind of like gonna add
special effects and everything
they didn't i guess they didn't like for
some reason they didn't want to use 474
for whatever reason so they opened up
340
and they kind of transferred the murder
story from 474
um to 340 but they kind of like
embellished it a little bit
and so now they have like when you do
the tour
um room 340 is the one where they have
like all the
like special effects and all the like
ooh ghosts like murder and [ __ ] like
that but nothing actually happened
happened in that room because that was
never a hotel room that's what i've
heard
so i don't know if that's true or not
and like i said i don't know if the [ __ ]
in 474 actually happened or not even
though i've read it on several
uh in several sources that there was
actually like a triple murder that
occurred in that room like it was a dude
that killed his whole family and then
killed himself
but and then like the you know whoever
like owned it at the time like covered
it all up because they didn't want
anybody to know
so i don't really know but that's kind
of like the story but like i said it
gets
misattributed to the wrong room so a lot
of people that stay in 340
um you know say that that's like the
haunted room but
probably the [ __ ] that would have
haunted the room was a different room
that's all i'm saying according to the
book that i read
okay i i don't know how true that is but
yeah so
uh another place that a lot of hauntings
take place uh
is the mauritania room now
allegedly in 1989 there were
two uh cleaning ladies and they get sent
to this particular
room uh this is like a lounge i guess
there's gonna be some like big
reception there with like some important
people and whatnot so they get sent
there like to clean it
they come in and
they said that they saw a dude
sitting uh in a chair like in the middle
of the dance floor
and he was just like sitting there like
kind of like not saying anything
so they're kind of like trying to be
like hey what's the deal and he just
like sat there and didn't
respond to them then another woman came
in came in
um at some point and was like uh
what's the deal with this dude just like
sitting in this chair in the middle of
the room but he's just like staring at
me
and he supposedly like asked her to
move or to get out of the room so
they thought that it was just a guy like
they didn't think it was a ghost
they thought it was like a person like
sitting in the middle of this room and
he wasn't supposed to be there so they
called security
and before security got there allegedly
this dude like just vanished right in
front of their eyes and three women
reported this
all happening at the same time
so let's see another uh ghost that's
reported this happened in the queen's
salon
this is another very famous one uh this
used to be
back in the days when this was a luxury
liner it used to be the first class
lounge like all the you know they had
all these like really fancy restaurants
and [ __ ] on the
uh on the ship and this was where like
all the
hoity-toity like rich rich people would
come and like they would
eat at the restaurants and they would
come and like dance at this place
so this place which is now called the
queen's salon
several people have reported seeing a
very very beautiful looking
young woman she has like a white evening
gown
and she is usually seen dancing
by herself sometimes with it sometimes
it looks like she's dancing with a
partner but i don't think anyone's ever
seen
anyone with her it just kind of looks
like she's dancing with somebody but you
can't see who it is you know what i'm
saying
but sometimes she looks most of the time
she looks like she's dancing by herself
and she's kind of like off in the corner
like in the shadows
so like a lot of people have seen her
and have said that she seems very
friendly like sometimes she will like
look at
you like if you see her and she'll give
you like a really nice friendly look
like hey there what's going on and then
like she'll kind of like disappear so a
lot of people have reported that as well
um there's another room called the
mayfair room
now this was uh used to be when it was a
ship it used to be the beauty salon
nowadays they use it as like the hotel
offices
now one report this this was from 2001.
i guess somebody that worked uh at the
hotel they were
like in the accounting department so
they come in early
to work at 5 30 in the morning
and she came in and she was kind of like
man like something feels kind of weird
in here
so she kind of gets about like doing her
work or whatever and then she sits down
at her desk and then she's like goddamn
it's like really [ __ ] cold in here
and then she said that she felt someone
like brushed the back of her chair
and then turned around and nobody was
there and then she said a couple minutes
after that
that she saw a figure
like wearing white but also kind of
see-through
they were like they walked across the
room and then they went through like the
wall
or through the door rather and um so
that woman like [ __ ]
took off so that's another place that
has been that people have seen
apparitions also there is a place
uh boiler room number four uh which
there's several boiler rooms on the ship
like i said they've all been
it's not a ship anymore so it's not
technically a boiler room because they
don't need that so they like cleaned a
lot of it out they still like call it
that
i think that if you go on the ghosts and
legends tour if i remember correctly
they use boiler rooms one and two like
on the tour like that's part of their
[ __ ] but i don't know if boiler room
four is like part of the tour or not
but some people have gone in this
particular room
and they have seen like a ghost of a
little girl in this area so it was like
a lot of like little kid ghosts on this
[ __ ] too
um this little girl i don't know if it's
the same one that's seen in other parts
of the ship
but she's usually seen with a doll in
her hand or she's sucking her thumb or
something like that
there is also another ghost that um
usually is called john henry
this guy is supposedly a welder and
the story goes that a couple of welders
um
died during the construction of the
queen mary
like they were either sealed inside the
hull accidentally
or they died from a gas leak or
something like that
so these two guys are like often uh
you know are attributed to like the
haunting later on
so this guy was supposedly one of the
welders that died when the ship was
first
under construction and this guy is
supposed to
haunt they call it the boiler room or
the green room area what what happened
was that
when they um you know made the
uh the queen mary from a ship into you
know the museum or whatever that it is
now
they took this one area that was a
boiler room and they cleaned it all out
and they made it like a theater because
i think like one of the colleges like
nearby like uses it like to put on like
productions and whatnot
so they have like a theater and then
they have like a green room and then
there's like a room with like a
generator in it or something like that
so this spirit that's called john henry
is supposed to haunt
specifically the generator room
so this is supposedly
this kind of like rugged looking dude
and a lot of people have
seen an apparition of him apparently
now one thing that's interesting about a
lot of the
male ghosts that are seen on the queen
mary i thought this is very amazing
but a lot of the male ghosts that are
supposedly seen on this including like
the dude that got crushed in the door
and
whatnot they seem to like
women a lot more than men this is what's
reported
so it's like if a woman goes through the
[ __ ] then they'll get
haunting [ __ ] but it'll be like like
somebody like just whisper in your ear
like stroking your hair
stroking your cheek something like that
pinching your butt which
that's that's right that's not good yeah
stroking and pinching and [ __ ] man
that's
right it's that kind of it's not not
that kind of [ __ ] yeah
but if it's a man then you'll get like
poked like like so the the male ghosts
apparently do not like dudes
yeah coming through they just want the
ladies we're dealing with the dude
that's what i'm saying well that's what
i said like all the alleged dude ghosts
are kind of like hey ladies i'm i'm dead
but hey
i can still i can still make you happy i
mean
i can still like stroke you on the
[ __ ] you know what i mean it's all
that kind of thing
but then if a man comes through like man
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i can't
i'm i'm not corporeal but i can still
like try to punch you from the afterlife
that's i guess that's what they're doing
now what's up badger
i thought he was there earlier i haven't
seen him i haven't seen him in a while
you're like why don't you talk for a
while so i can drink
what am i gonna say i'm gonna say badger
man send me a flash ball bro
it's early on in the night how much time
we got left i don't know we're
several hours we're almost at three
hours three hours show
almost two hours and 43 minutes god damn
i can't understand it
i can't understand what do you mean you
can't understand it you spent the first
hour we spent the first hour talking
about xanadu and talking about a whole
lot
i don't have the [ __ ] i don't have
the [ __ ] processing power in my
[ __ ] brain to understand no you don't
no mango said yep i have the same
problem i like women more than men too
yeah too yeah me too it should happen
you like women more than men well
it depends on how you're talking about
but it depends on what you're talking
about by like okay okay
maybe tolerate is about what it is
i tolerate women more than men we need
to hook up some more
threesomes
some
[Laughter]
who's going to be in the middle me or
her
uh me obviously are you going to be so
everybody's going to be worshiping you
in the middle obviously why the hell
would i even get involved in that kind
of situation
unless i'm gonna be the [ __ ] center
of attention i was thinking i was gonna
be the center of intensity that's how i
was imagining it
me being a man that's how i'm gonna
imagine it you know what i'm talking
about that's not how it worked out
well it almost worked out that way [ __ ]
man why are you getting me talking about
this
[ __ ] because it's funny come on people
love this they love it
people love this what happens is people
in case you don't know they start
fighting over you
they start fighting now
[Laughter]
well you know fights start breaking out
over who's getting most attention
well girls would like it if like
honestly i would like but it's gotta be
natural flow i would honestly like it if
two dudes were fighting over me
but that doesn't happen it doesn't
happen well
[Laughter]
dudes aren't most dudes aren't into that
[ __ ] which is a shame
i'm not ashamed that's a [ __ ] too many
dudes
too many stuff too many dudes man too
many stuff man [ __ ] too much
testosterone in one spot
y'all are just going to like not know
not pay attention to me and you're just
going to start punching it
yeah the smell man that's what it is man
somebody shows up man that
motherfucker's not even [ __ ] shaved
nut sack with [ __ ] hair it would be
it would be
it would be some [ __ ] like tyson
oh you said his name he said his name i
said it would be you
summoned him that [ __ ] was
always trying to do some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ]
him and all his [ __ ] chinese girls
and his [ __ ]
other ones that he picked up and then oh
my god you are opening up a whole camera
that [ __ ] was a mini me and he
was
trying to [ __ ] i know well this is
going back several hours
a long time this was like about four
years five years no it's longer
longer than that now it's probably more
like eight or nine years no it hasn't
been that long no it was because it was
like right when we were first first
getting together
yeah and that was like nine years ago
back when [ __ ] was [ __ ]
uh a free-for-all yeah cause i was
i was uh yeah back when she was a
free-for-all yeah on on top of some
other stuff
man i know that everybody was on time
we hadn't solidified the [ __ ] it had not
been solidified
it was you know it was still legit it
was so legit
i was still out that was when i was
dating that disney princess i remember
that remember that crazy [ __ ]
i remember that crazy [ __ ] yeah what
was her name again i'm not going to say
it on the show
all right wait i can't remember it i
thought i did but i guess i don't
megan oh okay yeah yeah yeah that's it
yeah why'd you say
it she was gorgeous but that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] crazy weren't you
she's a [ __ ] well yeah well
the thing about it you look good though
[Laughter]
well yeah and disney thought she looked
good and i thought you were like the
tenth one in the scene to banger
yeah yeah that [ __ ] that [ __ ] she made
the rounds
you know why that [ __ ] made the rounds
though she was insufferable
well yeah it's not it's not like it's
not like
she was doing the jumping around what
happens dudes are getting rid of her
yeah they're just like yeah okay
yeah because that's kind of that
remember me you me and you were just
friends at that time
yeah cause i was and i was i was like
dating someone else and i was like this
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] is crazy
[Laughter]
well i told you he doesn't listen though
dudes don't listen i had to get it
though like
i know but like chicks are kind of like
man that [ __ ] is crazy
but it wasn't just you telling me to get
away from that it was
[ __ ] sonia was also going well and
also all the dudes that had banged her
previously
but i was going to try it out and like i
said she was like a [ __ ]
a nine she looks like she was like i
said that he was super cute
i was going to try it yeah she was cute
but you know what i mean but
she was annoying and [ __ ] she was so
annoying she was like that [ __ ] wore
thin
quickly that's what i'm saying but
physically she was [ __ ]
sure but that only goes so far yeah it
wears off
pretty quick couple days later you're
like man you gotta get rid of this [ __ ]
it's like oh she's [ __ ] crazy oh no
like what have i gotten myself into it
didn't matter at that point though
i was like okay i see what i'm dealing
with now
now i'm telling my [ __ ] personal
business in front of [ __ ] what
thousands of people and [ __ ] but they
like the show because i say that that's
what i mean
yeah well like i said i i have no shame
i have no secrets about anything let me
tell you something people
okay she was cute
all right really cute um she
she looked kind of like kind of like a
sandra bullock but more
[ __ ] full figured kind of a body like
sophie d
porn star named sophie d she was built
exactly like that exactly like
like kind of like sophie d with a little
bit of a cuter face she was real cute
but that [ __ ] [ __ ] man tell you what
man she
you got sick of her quick he got sick of
her really quick i was just like
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy
[Laughter]
look seeing everything well here's the
thing that's saying everything
here's something that i learned thank
you meg flashball time
flashbulb time man go ahead bro here's
something that i
learned being the awkward weird girl
all through high school and college and
now you're still awkward
and yeah that's all right i own that
yeah
you act like it's an insult it's not i'm
just [ __ ] with you it's not
i'm just [ __ ] i am awkward and weird
i'm just like i said i'm proud of it
okay but
um here's something i learned and being
friends with
i was friends with probably i mean i was
friends with a lot of chicks but i was
friends with a lot of dudes too like in
high school
um you know gay dudes straight dudes
everything so here's something that i
learned
is that particularly young dudes they
will put
up with an unbelievable amount of
[ __ ]
to bang a hot girl and then
they will whine to me about it about how
annoying she is
yeah yeah but they will still keep
banging her and be like well
yeah she's hot though and i'm like yeah
but you're miserable
and you keep like whining alex alex
revere
alex rivera is on there going [ __ ]
looks we're off quick
and i keep telling them like look i'm
getting really bored of you like whining
to me about this [ __ ]
it's like just [ __ ] tell her to step
off why are you like
bitching at me it's just kind of i don't
care it's just kind of a conquest thing
you want to [ __ ] see
you want to [ __ ] spirit right but
then it's like why like [ __ ]
in her mouth man the more she'd [ __ ]
start talking the [ __ ] less
attractive she'd become you'd be like
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] annoying man
because girls should just not talk
[Laughter]
well fat girl in person bad girl i can
think of another girl in particular who
should probably not talk
which one would you do sonia no okay uh
i love sonia yeah okay
i don't know yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ]
talks too much and [ __ ] when she
opens her mouth she just puts her
[ __ ] foot in it and [ __ ] says all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] and [ __ ] just
like oh man
all all beauty starts to vanish
[ __ ] you know i mean all of a sudden
see now you start to understand how
women approach
dudes yeah whatever because no like i
said
looks are like made like that much
and it's like once you open your mouth
and start like spewing some [ __ ] i'm
like okay you're not cute anymore
bye you know what i mean it's like that
um
i feel like dudes have more tolerance
for well if they're hot
well she's annoying but whatever i don't
think so
but you saw me i tolerated it for how
long
uh a month i don't even think it was
that long
three weeks i think it was three weeks
about i was [ __ ] i was [ __ ]
i was i was [ __ ] hitting the [ __ ] out
of it and that [ __ ] [ __ ]
got [ __ ] old like in a couple days
well like i said you can see how yeah
and it's pretty bad because i mean we're
in the gaussian station it's very
incestuous everyone is like celebrating
everybody
yeah um i mean not yeah i haven't slept
with everybody that's the old
scene it's not around anymore but it
used to be back in the old days it's
like everybody had dated everybody
everybody knew everybody's business it's
like it's kind of like it was kind of
like that
so it's kind of like i mean and i had
heard i was friends with a lot of dudes
that had
gone out with her and i had heard the
same kind of [ __ ] from them
she's [ __ ] annoying right yeah
they're like well she was hot for like a
week or two but then
yeah you're like
[Laughter]
you're like shut up
and that's not everybody i know that
feel bro it's not everyone
it's just her she just shut the [ __ ] up
she shut up she might have lasted for a
couple more months
[Laughter]
just you're [ __ ] dumb see you're dumb
and you
honestly i would rather be like awkward
and weird
and sort of cute you're dumb you know
what the [ __ ] instead of like
super hot and super annoying and super
great super annoying and not knowing
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
[ __ ] saying
yeah i would say so as [ __ ] as
as you can hold a conversation
i mean i i realize i'm an acquired taste
i get that
i get that no i liked you right away you
were [ __ ] you're cool right i know
i'm a weirdo i get it
i get it but
i own it yeah like i said it's all right
we gotta get back to the show man
[ __ ] time is [ __ ] rolling off i
don't have like
that much no he doesn't okay seriously
so it's fine
um yeah where was i so
yeah john henry all right so
uh there have been some other uh
hauntings reported
in a bunch of the state rooms the first
class
state rooms um they've also like a lot
of people have seen like this weird like
he's like this really tall dark-haired
dude like all his hair is like slicked
back and [ __ ]
and he has like a 1930s style suit on
like a zoot suit type of thing
i think this is the guy that um
goes to the queen mary book calls the
dude
because like i said that they don't have
they have like all these like [ __ ]
names for this [ __ ]
um so a lot of people have seen a dude
that looks like that
um you know water running like i said
lights turning on and off phones ringing
in the
uh you know in the middle of the night
with nobody calling them
um some people have reported like
hearing a baby crying in certain rooms
um this has been attributed to oh maybe
somebody had a baby on the ship and it
died during
i don't know like i said a lot of this
shit's like unproven and a lot of the
[ __ ] kind of comes from
psychics that have been on the ship and
i've been like yeah i have i have this
feeling of like this little boy and his
name is this and that and the other so
like i said i don't i don't know like
how much of this is
really blah now i also want to mention
here
that one of the more popular uh stories
about the queen mary
is this urban legend about this dude
and he supposedly worked as a mess cook
during world war ii
um and i guess that
everybody that worked with him hated him
so much
that one day they decided hey we're all
gonna pick this dude up
and shove him in the oven and cook him
alive like [ __ ] hansel and gretel
style
and he died and so supposedly
that's like a cook that like haunts the
[ __ ] now
that is probably not the case there's no
record of that happening
however um there is
maybe a cook that died on the ship that
maybe was like the
the kernel of the you know story that
this like took place
so there was a dude
that was a cook on the queen mary
now he was actually on remember i
mentioned earlier that
the queen mary like took its final
voyage like when it was going to
long beach because it had been bought
and they were
like well you you know it'd be good if
you had like passengers on the last
voyage because that would like you know
offset some of the costs um instead of
you just having to like pay the
transportation costs like people would
actually pay to like
ride on the ship and it wasn't as
successful as they hoped because
like i said no air conditioning there
was like you know bad food that was all
kind of like
[ __ ] that happened people bitched and
moaned people got off at every stop and
it was like kind of a [ __ ] show
um so during that final
voyage where they had to go around cape
horn
apparently there was a cook on the queen
mary
that did die on the ship however he was
not murdered
he died of heatstroke
so a lot of people during that
voyage apparently were hospitalized for
various heat-related illnesses
but he was the only one that died and i
feel like over the years
that kind of became like somebody pushed
him into the oven like i said
hansel and gretel type of [ __ ] going on
so i kind of feel like that happened
he wasn't murdered he just died of like
heat strokes so there was a cook
that died so i think that's where that
legend came from because many people
have reported
seeing an apparition that looked like
a cook or like that struck them like a
cook
so also other people have said that
like they've been in other parts of the
ship and it heard like weird
knocks like doors slamming weird squeals
like i said earlier like um
the sound of like a whole bunch of
people screaming which may have been
attributed to
the uh kurakoa incident
um you know [ __ ] being like super cold
all of a sudden
um a lot of people have recorded uh have
reported feel uh smelling like
cigars like smoking and stuff even
though obviously nowadays like smoking
is a lot on the ship
but some people are like smelled cigars
so some people said oh it's winston
churchill because he spent a lot of time
on the ship and he had an office on
there his desk is still there
and the funny thing is that i saw a
picture of like winston
i was picturing here's what i was
picturing winston [ __ ] churchill
right look like a baby
well looks like a baby no babies look
like wednesdays babies look like we're
in
every baby
well when they said that winston
churchill's desk
was still on the queen mary yeah i was
picturing
like some fabulous like victorian i was
picturing like some
pimp and [ __ ] yeah it was nothing that
was it it looked like some like
sub ikea well it was like seriously it
was as wide as
it was like oh my gosh for like the
three days he stayed there
well however i think it was five or six
days
like across the atlantic but because
like i said he took this ship like every
time he went
over the thing because he really like
liked this [ __ ] but like because
it was like really luxurious like back
in the day but when i first saw the desk
i was like wait that's it
you can buy better [ __ ] than that like
from walmart nowadays
it's not sad yeah but back then that was
like kind of like the height of [ __ ]
luxury
it's like it didn't have it had it was
like this little bit it was like maybe
maybe four or five feet wide had a
couple drawers
that's it look at alex what alex said
read what alex said where right there on
the bottom of the group that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] funny
i feel like sylvia brown would get on
the ship close your eyes concentrate
this i'm getting a feeling
yeah what i'm getting to fit in the
water well she said that every [ __ ]
time
this is sylvia brown taking me back to
chicago and [ __ ]
that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah she said you
know she said those girls were dead no
they were down there in [ __ ] old
what's his name's [ __ ] basement
yep ariel castro castro's basement
yeah yeah she went on [ __ ] i don't
know
i think she died yeah yeah okay i don't
know if it was on geraldo if it was
another talk show so she didn't live
long enough to see him freed
oh now i have to look that up i'm pretty
sure she died like
fairly recently okay so maybe she didn't
every
um yeah she was actually she told their
families that they were dead
they were dead that was some that was
some [ __ ]
80s and 90s dead mall [ __ ] there wasn't
it
she's like something this is why i don't
like tv cycling
yeah tv psychics from the [ __ ] 90s
that's [ __ ] up
that was some [ __ ] bro i remember all
that don't like tell like
can you imagine if you were back before
your daughter
yeah had been kidnapped and you didn't
know where she was
and then you go on some [ __ ] i don't
know why you would but you go on some
[ __ ] talk show
i would never do that in a million years
but if you want to like some [ __ ]
talk show and you had some like second
and you actually believed that this
woman could like tell you
something you know substantive about
what had happened
to your daughter and this woman said oh
well they're dead
can you imagine like oh my god and then
like later they found uh
i just said she died in 2013. yeah i
thought she was dead
sophie man it was a [ __ ] that [ __ ]
sophie you would never understand
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you would never
understand the world that we grew up in
back in our day you were lucky to have
20
20 channels of television and only like
seven or eight of them were good okay
and you'd have some [ __ ] what is that
i thought
you were trying to get in but you'd have
geraldo and
sally jesse raphael they had these
things called daytime talk shows i don't
even know if they still exist anymore
they might probably
they were kind of addictive in a way
they were like junk food television you
could watch them
and it went by pretty fast and it was
just the the format of it
i tried to watch some [ __ ] like that
recently and [ __ ] it's hard to go
back to those days
very well you didn't have a lot of other
no options back then
zach said do you remember miss cleo i
remember yeah yeah she was like the fake
jamaican right
yeah that's right she's not jamaican no
sorry it's just so first
of all how much the world has changed
back in those
because back in those days it was a
top-down society
they showed you what they wanted you to
see there was no internet you couldn't
network you couldn't watch people that
you wanted to watch based upon
the information they gave you in the
past or the shows or basically like this
this is a highly targeted show this is
only to a certain kind of people that
like what we're talking about yeah
we're just it's custom you 9 000 people
yeah nine thousand
don't think we're annoying right yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
because apparently everyone else does
back when we were coming up
a show like this could never exist on
television maybe
something like on [ __ ] uh with like
local
tv yeah because i've seen some like
public access
back then and man that was like way
worse
it was much worse than what we were
giving you although
there were some public access legends
[ __ ]
sure there's a channel there's a [ __ ]
channel on youtube called wang
with a [ __ ] exclamation point on the
end he talks about some public access
legends
uh but it's just the flow of information
was
very narrow back then well i will say
that just for the record um
you know mystery science theater my
favorite thing ever
um started as a local tv show i mean
they had a local
it was in um you know minnesota
they were on a local tv station they had
a
when they first started they had a
[ __ ] call-in line
you could call in and like it would
record it like on their [ __ ]
machine or whatever like they had back
in [ __ ] 1989 or whatever it started
so not everything that was just locally
produced was bad
so that did i mean even though their
early episodes were very um
primitive uh you know there were
the seeds of like something greater in
that so i'm not gonna say that like
everything that was locally produced was
shitty because it wasn't
but i do feel like a lot of public
access stuff was just like
crazy people ranting you know what i'm
saying
yeah a lot of it was yes people are
talking about
in the comments we're talking about all
kinds of there was it was just a [ __ ]
different time man
in a way i liked it because okay look
alex jones couple days back posted a
clip
of david bowie back in the 90s talking
about the internet
and david bowie is prophetic as a
[ __ ]
well he was always ahead of everything
he was waiting alien maybe
he mentioned some aliens in the [ __ ]
in the clip he said
that's my conspiracy theory david bowie
was an alien well he was making jokes
about it
i know i'm making a joke he was telling
the interviewer he said
back in the 70s and 80s we were growing
up in one
truth and we also knew the one
lie there was also one lie and there was
one truth
but he said this internet thing is like
an organism
until itself all right it will fragment
society everyone will have their own
version of truth
and their own version of lie and
and i was just like what he was saying
and he said that it will be kind of it
will
grow exponentially and it and he says
we have no idea what medium will or
medium and media will look like in the
coming decades
he says because what people can will be
able to do in the future
he says it won't you know what i mean it
will just blow away
what we can offer in the traditional
media he's talking about movies and film
or it should be movies and tv which is
absolutely true
he's talking about shows like this shows
like this could have never
existed in the 90s and it's just
i thought it was [ __ ] what he said
[ __ ] blew my mind man
well like i said in a lot of ways it's
kind of like it's not
completely unprecedented because i mean
we grew up in the late 70s early 80s
when you had the democratization of
music yeah in the sense that it became
very much cheaper to produce your own
albums and tapes and [ __ ] like that you
could produce your own zines
um so the whole punk post punk
revolution you know based on that yeah
because i feel like
up until then you had to have a record
company you had to have like millions of
dollars behind you like you had to have
a studio you had all this other other
cases
but in the 70s yeah that all went out
the window and
everyone could do kind of do their own
thing and like punks were doing their
own thing they were starting their
labels so i kind of feel like it's it's
like the equivalent of that
right it's just like much it's on a much
larger global scale
that's all yeah but it's the same thing
but he was right
it did kind of fragment society he said
that the medium would be
tailored to specific audiences
and some of them would be very tiny to
give them exactly the experience
they wanted and and it would they would
fragment reality into you know what i
mean
millions of different versions of
reality of yeah
and million different versions of truth
and that's exactly what we're seeing now
the death of these
huge [ __ ] media countries companies
even
disney is in danger right yeah i mean at
least as far as entertainment
consumption is concerned i mean
i can easily i mean i have youtube i
have
i subscribe to you netflix i've
subscribed to you hulu i subscribe to
shutter
i have 2b which is free you know i can
just go on there i can watch
pretty much anything i want to watch at
any time that i would like to watch it
which is crazy
because if you grew up in the 70s and
80s
you didn't really have that luxury you
know it was funny is in the clubs man
[ __ ] in the early 90s it was kind of
internet was around but it wasn't really
a culture like it
is now we would do these club nights and
stuff down in new orleans and we would
use repediograph to make little fan
zines
goth fanzines and in them we would
mention all of our friends and
[ __ ] that they did it was kind of like
our version of the internet back then
and they would become kind of semi local
famous in the scene
based on some little bitty [ __ ] that we
wrote about them in a damn fanzine
yeah with little photos black and white
photos with a pediograph
we just stapled that [ __ ] together my
ex-wife's [ __ ] office
yeah in our off time
isn't that funny how reality has changed
so much
nowadays that would be nothing well like
but back then that was a big deal
in a lot of ways like i feel like you
know as shitty as some things are
nowadays
i do kind of feel like in a lot of ways
it's very much easier
especially for somebody like me that
back in the 90s
i was very frustrated because i felt
like
well i wanted to do you know i wanted to
publish stories i went into like
magazines i wanted to do
[ __ ] like that and it was like really
hard to kind of crack
any kind of i got like some music
reviews published like in a local
magazine it's like i did [ __ ] like that
but
you couldn't really break out on like a
[ __ ] national international kind of
thing to the extent that you can
nowadays right um
so the fact that you can do all this
[ __ ] now
like when the [ __ ] started i think the
first thing i got into
was um cafe press where you could
upload your designs kind of a graphic
designer too um
you could upload your designs onto like
shirts and mugs and [ __ ] like that and
you could sell them like in a store
and i think i finally that was like the
first thing i got into back in like the
early 2000s and i was like holy cr
[ __ ] crap it's like this is like
super cheap and you didn't have to like
put any money up and like people could
just like buy your [ __ ] and they you
know they would just like take a
bit you'd take a bit and it's like okay
awesome
and then like when self-publishing came
along i was just like holy [ __ ] crap
i don't have to like deal with anybody i
can just like put my [ __ ] up
i can design my own book covers i can do
all that kind of [ __ ] and it was like
[ __ ]
revelatory because that's what i always
wanted to do
i mean i don't like you know like i said
i'm a creative person
if i'm going to like write a book
i not only want to write the book i want
to do the layout i want to do the cover
i want to do everything i want
the product to be entirely my
product i don't want anybody else doing
the cover i don't want anybody else
[ __ ] up my layout
i don't want anybody else picking my
[ __ ] fonts i'm like a
control freak like that i want it to be
like an expression of my
vision that's what i want and so like
now that you can do that nowadays
that is [ __ ] awesome yeah i love it
sophie's talking about that too he said
that was spot on bowie yeah bowie
foresaw
all of this the internet
[ __ ] youtube [ __ ]
making [ __ ] through [ __ ] robots and
your own shirts
controlling your own personal media
target marketing it to a certain
audience
you foresaw all this and he foresaw the
[ __ ] breakdown of the [ __ ] old
school traditional medias the big
corporate medias he didn't think those
would survive
hey man that sexy [ __ ] back in
the day was entertaining me
through these through these albums there
was more to him than meet the eye that
dude was very [ __ ] smart
he understood the ramifications of the
technology
even back in the in the in the mid mid
90s he understood
what that would lead to i thought that
was astounding
well like i said you saw that you have
to think that
i mean even when you listen to his music
or like listen to any of his interviews
from the time
he was very very much ahead of his time
like he was very much on the cutting
edge of everything he was
always he was very high iq
very high he was someone that because i
feel like sometimes you get people that
are like you know they're real cutting
edge like in their youth or whatever but
he kind of seemed like
he stayed up to date right he very much
seemed that even when he was older
he was just like on the cutting edge of
everything that was going on at the time
he was very very much aware of what was
going on
and he was very good at like predicting
what was going to be like a big thing
later he was
really really good at that we saw him we
were seeing his [ __ ] videos up here
in this house when he was dying
his new album came out i didn't know
what he was trying to tell me but then
later on when he died we realized what
did what is he trying remember with the
[ __ ] videos of him the bandages
around his eyes
that he was dying of cancer because he
kept that [ __ ] quiet
but um very impressed with [ __ ] bowie
he lived a [ __ ]
outstanding life i mean he was he was
young when he was old
his whole life he just like lived it
with complete class
he knew what he was doing and complete
like integrity and here's another thing
about david bowie a lot of people don't
know this
okay he was one of the richest musicians
ever but the music didn't but his money
didn't come from music
uh the guy who made the most money on
music was michael jackson
but [ __ ] bowie was richer but he the
money didn't come from his music it came
from real estate investments
well bowie was a [ __ ] very yeah
intelligent same thing happened with um
i'm gonna say
paul mccartney um paul mccartney he made
a lot of money in music but he also like
invested in real estate art
like other things that were like he
diversified
is what i'm saying which is always kind
of like a smarter thing to do and i feel
like bowie did that [ __ ] as well
because you kind of have to think if
you're a
rock star quote unquote that's a
fleeting thing
it is you really have to like get into
some other [ __ ]
right if you're gonna like have any kind
of sustainability
like over the long term and i feel like
i mean especially back then
yeah might not be boy was the man might
not apply nowadays and i loved his final
words
tell them i was a closeted heterosexual
see that's what i mean even
up to the very end
it was all on brand oh no he said don't
tell her
don't tell them i was a clown a closeted
heterosexual
fantastic that was just kind of like the
[ __ ]
that was the chef's kiss on the end of
the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
like i said that was like some oscar
wilde [ __ ] either those curtains go or i
do and then
was pretending that he was gay
hilarious you couldn't ask for anything
about it he didn't like
he didn't go out like a [ __ ] he didn't
go out like he just like said that and
then he's like buy him out yeah
he went out and fantastic he went out in
the haze of morphine so
[ __ ] that's cool well like i said and
he didn't decide like i said he
he like kept control of his brand until
the very end
which like i said i respect that yeah
because it was kind of like just
he had this whole like [ __ ] um
curated life and curated death
which that's fantastic although i have
to say
do you remember we went to ibarr
um i think with the saturday
after david bowie died yeah do you
remember that [ __ ]
oh yeah i remember they played nothing
but david bowie they played pretty much
i mean they played some other [ __ ] too
but they played pretty much
like a lot a lot of david bowie like
that's right a couple hours yeah and i
was
i thought i was gonna cry and i'm like
man i'm gonna mess up my makeup i was
okay
until they played uh changes
yeah then i started crying everyone was
crying though so it was okay
everyone's dancing and crying it's all
right once we die we all go into the
[ __ ] cosmic [ __ ]
singularity you see bowie you know you
can experience a bowie
yeah [ __ ] i could tell i was taking
the acid
that's what i'm saying i'm hoping that
when i die it will just be like
yeah being on acid and being like yeah
[Music]
there's a lot of hauntings other people
have seen this blah blah okay yeah i
i covered it you're fine so um so you
can talk about other [ __ ] people
that's it but i'm just saying that um
i kind of i kind of hope like i said i
don't believe in afterlife or any of
that
[ __ ] but i'm just hoping that
when i'm dying i hope
that it'll be like urine acid
because it because that was one of the
best things about acid was just feeling
everything was okay we were all
connected yeah
and everything was the first time she'd
ever [ __ ] yeah and it's like cosmic
consciousness like i said i
i was like man [ __ ] i need to do this
more often because i feel like this
would be like a big help to people with
like mental health issues oh yeah i
think it is
that's what i thought because i thought
because i have like i don't have any
really like super bad like mental health
issues but i have like you know issues
with like depression anxiety [ __ ] like
that but it's like when that
when i took that i was kind of like
oh everything's all right yeah we're all
connected like the cause
it's singularity type stuff we're all
connected
so what if you guys have any questions
you can go ahead and ask questions now
maybe we can get to them and then it was
it was all like awesome
yeah mine my third drink seriously
another drink
no i said am i on my third drink
seriously
i this is my thing maybe yeah i think
that's your third one
zach says i'm worried if i did acid i'd
kill someone or cut my dick off
no i don't think that's gonna happen
well okay i'm not like i'm not
um an expert i'm gonna say i've only
done one time
no nothing would happen to you but
you've done it a couple of times
me you've done a couple dozen times okay
a couple dozen times yeah since i was a
kid yeah
i found it and like i said i've had
like you know i'm a depressive person i
have like
anxiety stuff and everything but when i
did that i could understand
you know how all the hit like annoying
hippies are just like oh we're all one
blah blah and i always thought that was
really annoying but
i get that now i get like where they get
that
sensation from because that's what
but that said you have to go
into when you do acid you have to go
into it with a mindset
that it's going to be good for you
because if you go into it like
yeah you can be fearful yeah it'll be
bad yeah then don't
yeah don't do that like if you have a
bad attitude about like oh
i'm going to have like a bad trip like
yeah don't do that because i kind of
feel like
the way that you approach it um has an
effect on how it
turns out it responds to what you want
right or what you're suspecting right so
you have to be i had a very very good
experience honestly
you have to be in a very safe
environment that's comfortable to you
around a bunch of good people that are
going to take care of you and then
[ __ ]
you can take it and it has to be an
exploration thing it can't be
wow let's get high and have fun thing
it's not what it's about it's
more of a [ __ ] inner voyage and inner
experience
it's spiritual it's the same thing the
indians were talking about with spirit
walk
and walking through the spirit world now
when i tell you about walking through
the spirit world does that make sense
yeah i know we talked about it yeah but
like i said i'm but i can see what
you're saying like if you're doing
it for the first time yeah because i had
never done it before he had done it
several times so he said i'm gonna watch
you like don't worry about it
you need to have somebody that's done it
before that's gonna want you because
if i had not had somebody that was
watching me i would have gone
in the backyard and started eating grass
because i thought i was a werewolf
yeah you remember that yeah but but
here's the thing
i don't think i would have liked you
would have actually done it i wouldn't
have done anything
bad i wouldn't have done anything bad
here's the thing i just thought it was a
werewolf
i've been i've been through that
situation before right you know what
have happened
you'd have gone out there and says i'm a
werewolf and you're [ __ ] you eating a
little bit of grass you gotta taste good
you to stop eating i'm going back
outside
you were just afraid that you would go
out and do it that's not what would
happen
but i'm glad that you were there like no
yeah i say no no no go outside don't go
outside yeah
after after at least after your first
trip
you can control yourself because you
know what to expect right
you know the you know it's like knowing
the rules yeah you know what i'm talking
about
but like i said and you don't have the
fear because you know
it's not as strong as you thought it was
yeah that was
that was another thing like that strong
i
took the first okay so this was the
first time i did it i did a hit
and a half yeah right i think so um
and i was expecting it to be much
stronger like i could feel it
but not not as much as i expected to
like i couldn't type on my laptop
because it was
like [ __ ] yeah doing like weird
distortion [ __ ]
but um it wasn't as over it was
like being drunk but you weren't you're
not intoxicated
right it's it's kind of hard to explain
it's like
it's like you're drawing but you're
still like coherent you could you're in
total control of yourself but right
you're observing things you're seeing
things
and you're kind of experiencing things
because like when you're drunk sometimes
it's like
yeah like sometimes i get drunk and like
the next morning i'm like what the [ __ ]
did i do last night like i don't
remember yeah eric jason it's not like
that
eric j says pure acid is better than
mushrooms yeah it is
it is i've had them both uh it's also
better than [ __ ]
peyote which i've had that also um
yeah good the best the best ass i've
ever had was from
well from a friend who was at the
university
i know who you're doing he's a
biochemist
okay they've studied at the university
of michigan we and him grew up together
and they were making [ __ ] in those
[ __ ] laboratories at the [ __ ] at
ufm back in the [ __ ]
80s or 90s 80s
actually late 80s and they were making
stuff
in that [ __ ] biochemistry [ __ ]
outfit down there man if i can blow your
mind
there's no difference cost wise
in making a few drops of lsd and making
a few
gallons of lsd so they would make the
ship by the gallon
now it doesn't have a long shelf life
sure and
so that means it really it's not really
uh it's not really
you can't really sell it so they just
gave it away yeah and that's
well yeah it's gonna go bad it's gonna
go bad and that [ __ ] there man was
[ __ ]
fantastic all right and it would just
take you to another [ __ ] planet
but the thing is is that you have to
respect it it's not
really a recreational
draw it's not something you want to do
every day it's a spiritual thing
and also i will admit it makes you feel
like
absolutely [ __ ] where's the next day you
will feel like
absolute [ __ ] the next thing but like
picture a hangover
yeah way worse than but a lot of good
music and a lot of good art came from
that
sure [ __ ] want to know what kind of
music can come from it listen to the
cure
the cure was very lsd inspired
especially like the kiss me kiss me kiss
me album
very lsd inspired um very psychedelic
you know but you
take it in the right environment safe
environment around
right people it's not anything it's not
a [ __ ] druggie drug really
it's not like like i said it's not
something you want to take all the time
it's just kind of something that is kind
of like it's almost
it's weird to say but it's almost kind
of like a treat yeah it's like a
spiritual journey
yeah you know we haven't had it in years
you know i mean
it's been a couple years since the last
time and
i don't did we tell the story about like
last time we took the [ __ ]
it was like a [ __ ] it was a weekday
it was like a tuesday right yeah
i was off work yeah and we decided to
take it on a [ __ ] tuesday
yeah we were like tripping balls yeah
and then like some
dude came to the door the mailman yeah
and i was dealing with the mailman that
decided for this [ __ ]
yeah he comes to the door and he rings
the doorbell
and the first thing we did was flip we
were hiding
we were hiding in a closet in our whole
house we're hiding
and we're trying to like we have a
walk-in closet it has like this little
bitty window
like way up on the [ __ ] [ __ ] and you
can kind of see the
front porch if you like climb up and so
we're trying to like climb up and like
look at it it's like
who is that we were like wigging out
we're like all paranoid
and we didn't want to answer the door it
was so [ __ ] funny
and then finally like finally he goes
and answers the door
and the dude thought it was [ __ ]
hilarious no i wonder if that dude still
tells the story i don't know
no maniac no [ __ ] what i'm talking
about about the [ __ ] not lasting
is that the [ __ ] that we were getting
from the university
wasn't on blotter it was liquid it
hadn't it hadn't been put on paper
and there was nothing to combine it on
paper it was just pure liquid
and that liquid stuff would disintegrate
evidently pretty quickly
it was very strong and uh
evidently it would lose its potency you
know the molecules would start breaking
down
evidently but if you put it on paper
they're using different kinds of
chemicals to [ __ ]
fix it you know what i mean yeah to keep
it preserved
but the real [ __ ] i think it was called
i think it was lsd 25
which is liquid and um it
you had to use it up within a month or
so and you couldn't sell a gallon of
that in a month
no there's no way yeah in a month it was
a half it was at half strength dj mating
access you need at least two days to
recover from lsd
yeah yeah i went to work the next day
and i still regret it to this [ __ ]
day oh
i felt so terrible yeah i don't know how
i got through that day honestly
i mean i had a good time yeah i know
what i'm gonna do on the [ __ ]
we took it early and like we had a whole
fun day with that [ __ ] we had a whole
adventure
but then i had to go like i was off work
on that tuesday and then wednesday i had
to go to work
and then i woke up the next day and i'm
like oh no
we got two thumbs down on the stream
it's always the same too
well you know i'm gonna beat a
motherfucker's ass
it's gotta be some kind of joke i mean
there's always two
yeah but why are they watching
i hate watching well here's the thing he
does some [ __ ]
people like that
i don't it doesn't bother me because i'm
like look
no one in the world asked you for your
opinion
and yet you gave it anyway but no one
cares eric said it was google
that's the thing that i would like to
say about everyone that down votes the
show it's like
no one in the world cares about it
before i make it three
no one in the world cares about your
opinion yeah oh are you sad now
okay everybody everybody's checking off
we're down to 40. now let's go ahead and
say goodbye we're going to get the hell
out of here jenny
all right time to [ __ ] shut it
[ __ ] ghosts
are on the show go to long beach check
that [ __ ] out
i guess you can still get there if you
like the show [ __ ] please share and
subscribe and like the show
we will be back in a couple days
actually we'll be back tomorrow we'll be
back tomorrow we are
tomorrow we're going to be talking about
uh
blood vessel blood vessel oh that's a
good movie yeah
we're going to review a movie called
blood vessel you guys might want to see
that on uh shutter it's on chad right
yeah it's a good movie good vampire
movie
it's a australian i think yeah about a
[ __ ] ancient russian vampires
on a nazi it's a [ __ ] yes it's nigh
yeah so you know all right so that'll do
it
like you can't even be bothered to like
stay for the end of the show
i'm here oh my goodness i'm here i'm
just putting [ __ ] up look at that [ __ ]
put [ __ ] up all right um we love you
guys
thank you for dropping by holy crap i
can't believe we can go
three and a half hours if you like the
show please
like share subscribe on all your social
media please like please subscribe
that really does help we're almost at 10
000. we're really trying to get there
also if you would like to financially
support the show you can go to our
patreon page
patreon.com 13 o'clock podcast
i only just started if you would like to
do an
annual subscription you can save 16
percent
so i might wanna go check that out i
just like [ __ ]
enabled that today so go see what that's
all about
but if you don't really like patreon if
you'd like to just kind of give us a
little bit
of tip or something like that you can go
to our blog 13 o'clock
podcast.wordpress.com
and there's a button in the sidebar
which goes to a paypal account
that goes to us covers all our [ __ ]
camera expenses or microphone expenses
all our various expenses
and it would be much appreciated and we
will see you
tomorrow like i said we're going to
review another movie
tomorrow we watch it already it's
awesome uh
so yeah thanks everybody for stopping by
we'll see you
tomorrow bye